What should we talk about?
I guess bodies.
Terrible.
Yes.
I'm glad we missed that whole blue.
Oh,
what's up everybody?
It's a Brendan shop and Joe Rogan and Whoa.
This is the fight companion light is to tell the slimmed down version.
Eddie Bravo is doing a Jujitsu seminar today in I think in Whittier and uh,
Brian Cowan is in Utah tending to play golf with his dad.
Yeah.
He plays golf and he acts like he enjoys it.
Papa doesn't really.
Yeah,
that's right.
I think he kind of likes it,
but he,
you know,
he can't go.
Wow.
He probably just likes hanging out with his dad.
You've got to do things like that.
You do,
man.
Yeah,
I mean checks.
Pretend to be in the football so can hang out with you.
That's true.
Someone to actually get into it.
I'm just being offensive.
So Brian,
Barbara Arena and uh,
who's the other gentleman?
Something.
Edwards Edwards.
What's his,
uh,
do we have a fight card?
Jamie could put that shit up on the other screen and this UFC Rotterdam reminds
me of UFC 100.
This thing is epic.
How dare you show up late Joe Rogan.
It's a lease that rest in shape.
Yeah,
it's,
it's about as good as shape as you can get beer.
Rapido it clipped Brian.
Barbarian is the dude who choked out.
Sage Northcutt very tough fighter.
Leeanne Edwards.
That's right.
Leon got,
there's not a lot of Leon's left in the world is,
that's right man.
You met dude.
That was a big name in the 70s.
You had no guy.
Oh,
he's got the back one hook.
Brian Barberino is very good on she ground.
Interesting.
Do you see the fire man?
See that fire last night?
Where was it?
Cause I woke up my,
my,
my uh,
my slingshot was all covered in ash.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah,
it's out near Burbank.
Is it really?
Yeah.
It's already the biggest fire in the history of California.
Los Angeles Rather.
Yeah,
because it's in Los Angeles County.
It's the biggest fire ever in Los Angeles County.
I think it's burned something like 5,000 acres are ready and our people
evacuating their homes and shit and they were in danger.
They,
they're evacuated in Burbank.
Burbank.
But a good chunk,
Tim.
I've seen any of the news.
Gary coming home looking up the highway.
When you see the hills on fire.
Really?
Damn.
That's scary.
It's kind of close to you.
No,
no.
It's not close to me,
but I can see it from some sponsor closer.
It's close to a Brian red band.
He lives out there.
Look at that fast moving while evacuated in la in Burbank.
You know,
I talked to a fireman wants man,
he fucking freaked me out.
He goes,
it's just a matter of time until one day it burns all the way the water.
And I went,
what?
And he goes,
Yep.
Just a of time.
One day.
Oh Brian,
Barbara.
And I'm like,
he fucked her.
Oh No,
you just stay on that opposite hand.
Yeah,
I'll just give him get his chin broke.
that opposite hands.
Firefighter sounds like a drama queen.
No,
no,
no.
He said they're east coast with the right combination of dry weather and the
right wind and he goes,
once it hits the buildings,
we won't be able to stop it.
He see those little burn all the way to the water?
No,
he was an older dude that was like super stoic.
That's why it made me shit my pants.
Really?
Yeah.
It wasn't like some Dork.
Let's talk slash math man.
Have you ever seen,
you know,
the,
uh,
new papers on top?
Oh Shit Dude.
He's under the chin.
Yeah,
he's in trouble now.
Oh,
ah,
sideways.
Sideways.
He's okay.
Leon's definitely doing work.
Yeah.
Leanne almost had that if he maintained back control,
they're like,
if he had a like some Marcello Garcia style hooks,
Goddamn you might've got that back.
That firefighter hitting on are scary as fuck.
He was.
All he was saying was,
he goes,
there's only so much we can do when a fire,
it gets out of control with strong wind and dry ground.
He don't like,
this was right after,
I don't know if you around,
um,
California in 2002,
I think somewhere around there,
2000,
2003,
I got evacuated.
Um,
and uh,
we were coming home from fear factor.
We're filming out in uh,
like north up on the five and as I was coming home for a whole hour on the right
hand side of the car,
the hills run fire that whole hour in the car driving personally in other years,
like your old house like out there?
Yeah.
No,
but I'm just saying on the way home from like to hone,
you know,
like to hone ranch.
The whole right side of the highway was on fire for an hour.
That's how much was on fire.
I'm talking like 50 miles of shit on fire.
I got never seen anything like in my life and when I was talking,
I mean it was like Lord of the rings type Shit was crazy scary.
All the hills were on fire.
I mean every of the right hand side and everywhere you go it was like snow fall
with ash saw dead guy.
So I dude got hit by a car I was trying to run across the road and he got
clipped.
Yeah,
there's a fire and your flat,
Gosh,
Shit.
Yeah.
We saw this dude laid out with his sneaker off and I was like,
oh no kind of sneaker with Reba.
I don't remember.
You would know.
I would know Lumas those 13th
13th you imagine like God,
they look fresh down like he's not going to be gravel.
It's what they did in the old west days.
Hopefully they're not at Murphy's Cathleen Hubbard.
He wasn't close enough to the fire.
He was just on the highway.
But I think you know,
people panic.
Both the driver and the guy tried to run across the borough.
Can you imagine the kid,
could there be a worst way to go?
Burned alive?
Like I was watching game of Thrones.
I'm on season five now.
When they burn homeboy,
don't say anything.
Spoiler,
it's been out way too long.
Coils come on.
It's the best show ever.
Forever
take gets better.
Seven the way season seven ends,
you're going to be like when the last episodes over and the goal is to black.
You can go,
no
dude.
Oh,
I make myself a little drink.
Such a good show.
It's so good.
Such a season five.
Yeah,
it's so good.
The new narco started and I just,
I can't do it,
man.
I'm crushing hard on game of Thrones,
so I don't want to like cheat on and watch Norcos I had abandoned narco second
season.
Why?
Um,
Coldwell and that's all.
I don't watch it by myself.
My wife was like too many people getting shot.
Too many people get shot.
It's my cartels.
Shit went to murder sometimes because she's cool.
Like game of Thrones.
It's fake.
I mean,
the only thing faker the dragons,
everything else pretty legit.
It's fake.
Even that's up for debate.
You know what's bad ass Ozark?
I'm on season one.
He told me that I need to get to that episode to rather episode two of Ozark.
God Damn.
It's good.
Damn.
Your wife won't fuck with Nok Cause,
Huh?
Not Anymore.
I can't do two shows at once.
I'm like,
I don't want to,
you know,
like I said,
I'm crushing hard and game of Thrones.
I don't cheat on with narcos and I can only handle so much narrative.
You know what I'm saying?
She barely got through season one and season two.
It was just way too much.
Merkin I mean it's,
I get it,
but it's like drug cartels.
That's what they do is what they do.
That's also real life.
It's real life.
Know how much they embellished.
Not much.
If you know,
if you look at the history books with boy,
he was definitely a bad guy.
Hirable person.
But you are rooting for me.
Knocked cause one I was like I hope he gets out.
I like his posture was belly and it just didn't give us fuck and we just give
zero fucks.
Zero your show rich and just hooking up with chicks.
Non Stop.
How about when they blew up the federal building or whatever the fuck when they
bought the plane just he just blew up the plane and fucked everybody like no,
fuck it.
Fuck it.
And then he ran for what?
He ran for governor and just start killing everyone.
I think he's Brazilian.
Brazilian.
Yeah.
It's fucking good.
He's good,
right?
Fuck yeah.
And the new season's about the Cali cartel,
right?
Oh Man.
I don't even want to know.
I just feel bad that they're not gonna keep Pablo Escobar round.
They need to like go like have a Prequel,
like you know what they do with star wars.
Oh,
I'm,
yeah,
I'm about that.
I would say jump on into that El Chapo life.
Look at Mr. Steal your girl face there.
Would you like a mansion?
That dude had so much money.
He had a burry it.
Yeah,
and he was like,
he was losing money cause the wrath,
we're fucking with the money or eaten his money like $1 million straight up.
That's how rich you are when rat,
they're fucking up your funds and you don't give a fuck.
He was making too much money.
Like literally he had hippos and Shit.
Yeah.
I'd fly him out there and just watch them attack each other and shit.
But then he was like a great dad.
Do you see that document on his son?
No.
Hit to change his name.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
because his last name is Escobar and he's like,
yeah,
he's like apologizing for his dad.
Hey,
what are you going to do for sure.
Just to own it.
Make Pablo Escobar tee shirts and sell the shit out of him.
Could you imagine if your dad was Pablo Escobar means can say you're fucking
right.
I did won't up airplanes and shit man.
Oh,
Barberini clip.
get up Leon.
Leon's in trouble.
God dammit Leon.
That ref is anxious.
Leon got to get that hand up.
You gotta move
to get there early.
Bob Written a second for that front choke.
Alright.
Spins.
It takes the back.
Oh yeah,
just keep punching.
So they stopped it.
You got to move.
There you go.
You Leon.
Why we written up for Leon?
Cause he's name's Leon.
I told you there's a travel advisory from Mexico.
Yeah,
I know.
Freaked me out.
But they're only killing each other.
You know what I'm saying?
But for now,
yeah,
occasionally they go dark.
Do I get that?
But I look Mexican,
so then I'm like,
Ooh,
maybe the key first or they kidnapped me.
I'm like a sex slave.
Ooh,
Ooh.
I,
there's like Mr Schaub,
we will talk about the,
Oh we love Mexico.
We will have a Mexican cans,
but they're too short to join.
So we brought you in to the VA sex slave,
going to impregnate to all these beautiful women.
Ah,
with your perfect DNA.
Yeah.
I'm just like a stud horse.
Exactly.
Just slang in deck out there.
But you guys think I'm being tortured,
but it's awesome.
Just getting pussy in a slingshot
drugs,
Pussy.
You guys think I'm being tortured.
But it's awesome.
Just Viagra and different drugs that make you grow calm.
We have this new thing.
It's a mixture of zinc,
magnesium,
steroids,
and you're just loads or just building up in your balls.
But I got to make videos that like,
yeah,
I make porn.
Make videos like being mad at America and Trump and shit,
but you guys can tell him happiest fucked.
I'm jack from all the steroids.
Yeah.
And girls like pulling on you and you're like,
stop.
Stop.
Please not,
not gonna say this wall.
It's fucked up.
And it's the reason why I'm stuck here.
I mean,
please,
please bitch.
One second.
God Damn.
And you just write it out and then you see just a bunch of supplements in the
back and the healthy for V,
you're the tip of your Dick Peaks.
You're on these,
I'm like,
go fucking telescope.
You're framed in the nipples up
like the chest burster an alien one.
No,
he sees all you see is like
fucking painted red fingernails pulling on
America's fucked up with that wall.
I'm telling you guys,
they're not going to ease up on me either and you are not going to make Mexico
pay for this wall.
Mr. Trump,
senior Trump senior Trump.
Oh,
it's just the time of my life.
Hopefully fucking seal team six.
Save me
boys.
Please,
please stick around for awhile.
To my man,
they're grilling steaks.
Want to make sure you're
still killing it.
He just making babies make this like the opposite of like when a viking comes to
town and he didn't want to have got their own way
they want to recruit.
It's just a dick.
All the girls down.
Yeah.
Like for real.
If you were that dude like the mountain,
that mountain guy from game of Thrones.
Yeah.
I guarantee that guy could sell his calm.
This is the thing though.
Have you seen him?
I hear you.
Have you seen him before?
He fucking took all the Jews.
He was a basketball player.
He was skinny as fuck.
His genes aren't that great.
It's the juice.
Oh really?
Bringing that up.
Bring that shit up Jamie.
If he can.
Yeah,
he was a basketball player.
Look at them.
Look at them now like he was like a giant basketball player.
But what is he like 17 there?
How old is not a bitches these 30 though?
See
Jamie.
Right?
But is there any other pictures of him?
Look,
21 and 25 on the right.
Look at that little bitch.
What's going on with his eyes?
A couple of crazy eyes.
Somebody left.
You says genetics aren't amazing.
Wow,
that's crazy.
That's,
that is a strong juice appetite.
Steroids.
Hell of a drug.
God Damn.
Did you see that dude that just died?
That rich.
Wow,
Leon's got it back again.
But this time he learned from his past mistake.
Oh,
Leon got to.
Yeah,
I've got the,
uh,
you've got the body triangle.
He's done.
He's done this rough,
just gut hanging over everybody.
Bob.
Bob Arena is so tough.
Damn smart.
Worried doesn't give a fuck body lock on the,
that's a dude that knows how to train hard.
You know those dudes that can just train through nice toenails bro.
Oh,
that's supposed to grab the cage,
sir.
Sir.
Stop grabbing the cage.
It's toenails.
Yeah.
And then where is it?
You can grab the cage with your toes.
That's a weird one,
right?
It is a strange one.
And they freak out about,
I feel like they see that more often than the hand grab.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
But some people let it go.
Like that guy just let it go while Leon,
it's still working it man.
But he's not really that close.
Is he like the,
the chin?
Well it depends on what kind of squeezed he's got it.
He's got one of them.
Damien.
Why Maya squeezes.
Yeah,
game over to stay with my on your neck.
Like just doesn't have enough power.
I mean literally it's like Torque and power at this point.
Like if [inaudible] gets a hold of you or,
or Marcello,
you know,
joc array of pop your head off.
Oh yeah.
If he gets this like kind of under your Chin and you're in this position was get
the body lark.
Barberino smart though.
Leaning on that one side.
[inaudible] get out to those.
I turn around lunch,
he's going to end up in guard like he's going to the college.
Get our Sel Leon control the arm that was very smart.
Controlled that right arm with a double double risk rock.
That's a move.
You hardly ever see the reverse armbar yet.
Very rarely do you ever see that.
Be kind of be a bit of a meathead to really submit somewhere that [inaudible]
though.
Or does it like a strain?
You know the last time we saw it ready for this hoists,
Gracie and Matt Hughes,
God who's got a hoist Gracie's arm and that fucking stay girl.
Double risk.
Armbar think that's how he got them right.
You'd have,
you'd have to surprise the shit out of somebody or they have some patents,
some cranky power.
Boom.
Matt Hughes is just got that crazy farmer.
Gorilla strength.
How bad.
But also technique too.
And then he just took his back and just smashed him.
How about he's doing better?
Yeah.
You see him?
She was going to get Sushi and shit.
Yeah.
Well he's rolling.
He's actually rolling with his friend.
They like,
he was in his guard working.
I asked.
That's crazy.
Last pap milicic about it.
Cause I,
you know,
I didn't know and asked him,
he was just saying how,
you know,
trains the denial and they're like so far away and if you wait for him,
you're going to be there forever.
So Matt was like,
fuck this and Florida's truck.
But the gravel,
it didn't go like you thought it was gonna take off.
And that's how I got hit by the train.
Oh my God.
I know that it's so crazy,
but doing better now.
Yeah.
Well probably because he's such gorilla,
you know,
I'm sure that body such in phenomenal shape.
If you were like this Raf,
you'd be dead.
Yeah.
Be Over.
He'd be over.
Yeah.
Shade me.
He's just a tough son of a bitch.
You have to know to be a ref.
God,
I don't feel like,
well,
there's a c there's,
there's levels to this game.
There's big John,
there's of Dean and then it falls off like a motherfucker.
It's kind of like the light heavyweight division.
There's like two bad asses than the rest.
Well,
there's other really good ones.
You know who's a really good one?
Um,
oh shit.
Damn.
So this is an interesting fight,
right?
Because Leon had his back twice,
two rounds in a row.
[inaudible]
Leon came close to choke him but didn't finish him.
Leon definitely won the fight,
but there was at one time try and almost put them away.
It's not 10,
eight though,
is it?
I don't know,
man.
What are these new rules and when are we going to use them universally?
And you're in Rotterdam.
Hey,
we got two super important things to talk about.
One does this Jon Jones thing,
people keep saying that Jon Jones,
um,
because of this drug tasks,
he did a a a blood test and he did tested negative,
the blood test tech and tested negative past the blood tests failed the urine
test.
Here's the thing,
the,
the blood test doesn't test for that stuff.
Correct.
I'm getting it straight from the Wicki.
Oh,
you talked to her.
Do you talk to the Golden Snitch task?
Because they can talk about it because John has gone public.
What?
Correct.
The blood test is not test for this tee ball stuff,
whatever the phone call.
But the urine test does.
Correct.
So they have to urine samples and then the results of the urine sample B will be
out soon.
And then we'll know what game changer.
And he said with Toronto Ball,
it's so old school,
like if you're going to do that,
you basically whoever's giving it to them has their black belt in a pds.
So if you test positive for Toronto Ball,
you're probably stat they miss the good stuff because you're stacking that with
a bunch of other shit.
It's not like just can take some old school tran and ball and not take anything
else.
This is so crazy.
How weird is it so crazy?
Cause I did not,
if,
if this is true,
I did not think that he was a cheater.
Really thought that he was a guy who was fucking off and partying and got busted
with some freak shit that sends some Dick Pills because they tested those high
number of tea.
I never bought that narrative.
Here's two options,
right?
There's two options when it comes to those Dick Pills.
Those Dick Pills did have the steroids in them.
But do you know that?
Why are you taking them?
Because if you just take them and you're getting steroids too,
you're getting steroids and your Dick,
but not enough where it's gonna be a performance.
Hank Lake,
it's such a small micro dose of uh,
testosterone.
Where the fuck is in those things?
He gets a clomiphene,
right?
Yeah,
whatever it is.
But I just,
I,
I think John has some smart people around him.
They painted that narrative where like,
oh yeah,
he's a party.
He was taking Dick Pills.
That makes sense.
Why you would test positive for this stuff?
When I feel like the recipe,
when the know were like,
uh,
not really well like this monster be taken.
I get you dick people down.
If Dick people down in my day before to never have to fucking turn towards Dick
Pills.
You know what I was like,
I like to party as much as the next day.
Not John Jones.
There's levels to this party game that Jon Jones style.
Well he obviously had coconut system too.
He does like to party for real.
We get that.
And then that's what you know Brian Red band called it because people that do
coke,
the Dick doesn't work that good.
So then they stack it well with,
with a vacuum.
It's Dick.
And I was like really?
And he was telling me about,
cause Brian loves those God damn gas station Dick Pills,
but he's like,
they're totally inconsistent.
He's like,
you'll get one,
you get these raging hard ons,
you get another one,
you feel like a homicidal maniac.
Like you,
you get crazy aggressive.
Don't want that in my life.
You know what I'm saying?
But I see,
I just,
I never bought that narrative with John.
I did it.
Well,
now we know.
You know the,
the urine test from a is positive because that's what tested for that substance
in the urine.
The blood test is irrelevant.
They weren't tested.
See?
But,
and then,
then people that don't get that,
you see,
oh,
but he passed the blood test.
Right.
You guys are full of Shit.
It's like,
no,
no.
The urine is the big one here.
I saw that his own doctor was posting that on doctor hightower.
I guess this is chiropractor doesn't count.
Yeah.
Who's posting on Instagram?
Free.
John Jones.
And I was like,
cool.
Well this is not like smart to Saddleback.
You're talking about the wrong substance,
the wrong test rather.
No,
they just don't get it.
I
think now my phone,
I don't know what's going to make us like,
God dammit.
Is it or is it the fucking do with weed?
The fire is burning down.
Yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
My car was covered in ash this morning.
Yeah,
it's out there,
bro.
It's scary.
Yeah.
But with John,
you got to listen to what Chil chill had a good narrative and I think I don't
have many hour with Air Hawaii.
He was just saying that's such an old school drug like to be associated with
that and does pause for that.
And he was,
I got,
you know,
he said the same thing cause I know a few things about pds for God's sakes.
Yeah.
And so he was saying that old school drug,
they're missing the good shit.
Like he got away with a lot of other stuff.
If you're,
if that's in your system,
you just don't,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like if you want a car,
you're not going to just get a fucking 64 Ferrari Daytona.
You got to start with some other shit itself was civic.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
With a one bad tire that I'm bringing to the game,
there's levels to this for God's sakes.
What do you think happened?
Uh,
you just got caught.
Yeah,
I,
well I and uh,
I'm sure you could talk to you.
The uh,
Novitsky when I said Golden Snitch,
that's a complimentary term.
I don't dislike the guy think he's clean up the sport anyways.
It's clean up.
Go and snatch and that's a good beer.
20 beers back there.
I would like a beer.
I wouldn't mind a cold one too,
man.
It's the world's burning down dot.
That's not the same if there is,
it's really old,
but I'll all a studio.
We've got to make sure we have fucking beer on his,
gets some kegs going.
That's what I'm talking about.
Get a couple.
There was a funny picture that somebody put on Instagram,
a meme of two giraffes going at it and they're like,
this is true.
They are huge man and giant fucking huge.
Is this the first time I was just a fight pass contender series?
I hear this with very good people.
Dig It.
Powerful cats and gone home.
Oh Pow or full cat thing.
Gun for sure.
Fight again.
Um,
I think she was saying that she was having some like some headway shoes.
Yeah,
she's talking about right now.
Just talking about what's going on right now.
I don't know.
Jamie and the other one being this beer.
Goddamnit and Jamie.
She probably talked to him about it.
What is she talking about?
She wanted to fight.
Crank this up.
Jay Wu.
I'm not mad at that.
Jamie type mood cranked this up so we get here.
What?
She's talking cat Zingano photography.
Oh,
it's her photography.
It's like a documentary.
Well,
I'll watch it.
Oh,
GSP crank this.
He's big right now.
I saw him in uh,
in Vegas.
Thicker than a snickers.
Yeah,
he does a pretty sick,
but he's got muscle thickness.
Right.
He doesn't want,
he doesn't want to be light.
If he's going to fight Michael motherfucking Biz Bang.
I'm excited to see how the fight goes down.
I don't think it's as big as it draws.
Everyone thinks though.
No,
I think you're correct.
I think a lot of people have passed or zipping up his lip.
Like he's not saying anything.
Well,
maybe you should start talking to,
cause that's how you make money.
Both.
You started talking chairs,
brother
again goes back to Madison Square Garden.
Yeah.
Actually if I did commentary,
but I said,
I'm only doing an English accent.
We're from now I'm wearing a bow tie.
If you wear a bow tie,
I feel like people do revolt.
Just fuck this dude.
Think it's adorable.
No,
I,
I don't know man.
I feel like people make you look good in the boats.
I thanks man.
Thanks Bro.
I'm thinking that turn it pink.
There's a pink bow tie.
Just all pink.
Uh,
that card stack though.
It's a great card.
What's on the card?
Uh,
you got Tj Dillashaw,
Cody Garbrandt,
which is the best way to link card.
That's a good fight.
Great fight you got,
uh,
and that,
this might,
I don't know if this is confirmed or not.
You might know Jamie are,
you might know him,
probably do a fucking promo for it.
A Mazda doll versa.
Wonderboy.
Yes.
It is confirmed.
Yeah.
That's some of the fucking fight.
I haven't done that Promo for that yet.
Oh yeah.
There's some good fights on there.
Look at that.
Johnny Hendricks,
Bora Cina Johnny Hendricks still fighting.
Sliding back,
man,
not,
yeah.
Is that for us?
The hobbies?
Uh,
brother.
Oh,
it is?
Yes.
Damn,
that's right.
Yeah.
Good for him.
He's supposed to be a bad ass.
He better be if your brothers for us.
I mean you better know some shit.
Yeah you should know some shit dropping the ball man.
It looks like Thomson and Mazda at all.
Cause I was the first fight in the main card.
Nice.
Tj Dillashaw and Cody Garbrandt a big fight man.
This is,
this is why this car is so good.
So busy being a Saint Pierre.
It's a good fight.
It's not going to knock your hair back but it's a fun fight.
We don't know who's going to win that garb.
Rent until shawl.
God Damn.
That's a tough one to pick.
And then soap car brand saw back is 100% I'm sure it is.
It sounds like it is.
You know what I'm saying?
He's back training and just I hate,
I hate to see someone with a back injury.
Rush it back cause we kind of taking this time though.
Yeah he's a smart kid.
He's around good people and he's been at the youth as much as he was.
He'd been,
God,
it's been a minute.
Remember this was filed a while ago and he even push it back even longer and
people were like talking shit to him.
But I think it's very smart and calculated.
Definitely smart dude.
He has potential to be a superstar.
Fuck Aa does.
Um,
and that's what really interesting.
Fine,
great fight.
And Dominick Cruz,
Cody Garbrandt was to s what does that December 30th okay,
so 2016 so a that's an interesting man.
So that's quite a while ago.
It get enough and he wouldn't rush it back.
Switch be in champion.
Really don't have to rush back.
So you got Tj so eight months after that fight and when did his back at her,
did you get hurt and training?
Yeah,
cause we are where they're supposed to fight in that on that Vegas card.
Right.
The July card.
I just hope he's done everything.
I know a,
he was doing some of that Regina king stuff to try to get a sense from the
Germany,
didn't they?
Yeah.
He went over there and got that treatment.
He's a smart kid and he's young too.
That's the other thing on his side.
And he doesn't have a lot of miles on them.
Right.
I bet he's going to be all right.
And then Tj has the teachers doing a lot of his camp out here and he's,
he's making things up.
It's got such a fight.
It's a good fight man.
And that gives plant in.
Teachers never slacked off from the time they were first supposed to be scared
of easiest in super shape and he's like getting better constantly with the odds
are on that flight.
To me clothes,
it's such a good fight.
I think the big factor,
one of the big factors is Cody's hands,
his power,
power and speed of lightning.
Lightning combination fast too.
But then Cody's fast with crazy power.
Yeah.
But I feel like Tj see Cody's take down a fence is really getting his is really
getting as fast as fuck.
But then TJ mixes it up.
So wellness footwork,
but then Cody's footwork against Dominick Cruz was ridiculous.
Fantastic.
It's a really good fighter.
I think Tj is going to be better than he was against Dominick Cruz too.
You know,
I think the Dominick Cruz fight,
he was super emotional and he got real flat footed.
And there was times in the fight where he was like loading up,
looking for a big shot.
Yep.
Trying to finish a mom can't do that to Dominic.
He's just not going to be there.
See,
here's the thing,
Cody Garbrandt verse Dominick Cruz,
is Cody that damn good way just outclassed Dominick Cruz or did Dominick Cruz
had an off night or do they just do the not match up?
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
I think Dominic is,
you know,
fantastic fighter,
but he's had some foot issues too.
You know,
Dominic has got that plantar fasciitis.
Yup.
Yeah.
Well massive surgeries,
right?
He's had both knees operated on more than once.
He's had a torn groin muscle that fucked him up.
Like he's had something,
some [inaudible] for a minute.
He also works for UFC nonstop.
Yup.
And now that Brian Stan retired,
I assume that he's gonna work more nonstop.
So what's Cody and Tj doing while you're working for the UFC?
I don't think you can do both and be as successful as you want to be,
not to be the dynamics.
So damn good.
And he's kind of,
you know,
he's so good where he can pull it off and still,
beat anyone in the world.
But to be like legend status.
See,
I don't think John,
well that's a bad example.
I don't think calmer could do,
could work for UFC and night work with you on UC paper using be Connor Mcgregor.
That makes sense.
It does make sense.
You know,
I think the big factor in that fight was a,
the speed and the combinations.
A Cody,
there's landed more often.
There were just better,
you know,
like he was connecting on Dominic and Dominic was throwing things just a little
wider.
And then Cody was just getting in with those shots like multiple times.
Clipped him with harsh and Cody lands,
you're like God Tam at 35 click a little Mike Tyson and he's obsessed with being
the best,
you know?
Yeah,
very interesting fight.
He also speaks well.
All he cares about is fighting his,
he has the s him and Kevin,
we have the most potential,
like your next breakout superstars,
nine grain.
The thing about,
uh,
TJ though was Tj has more weapons.
Like TJ does more stuff like Cody.
Um,
although he does kick and does throw knees and does throw elbows.
He's so good at boxing that you see in my prime,
predominantly up like a boxing oriented style.
And too though he's a phenomenal wrestler in high school.
Tj though is like he'll mix it up more with kicks.
Yeah.
Tj.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's like,
he's more of a Swiss army knife where fucking Cody garb and it's like a goddamn
machete if that thing lands game over.
It's already has ridiculous footwork.
Good way to put it.
But he's like a Swiss army knife.
You base a lot of tools.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know,
Dominic Cruz set the blueprint and then Tj Dillashaw download it.
Proud to next level and current Cody Garbrandt and even download that,
brought the next level.
He brought it to the next level of Dominic beat him.
It's true.
Did he beat him though?
No,
I think as a draw.
Me Too.
I think it was as close to a draws a human can get.
I just,
I don't understand those fights.
When who the fuck knows and you decided one guy's the champ and one guy's a
loser.
You got to pick someone though.
I know.
It's crazy.
It seems like in a fight like that,
that seems like a draw to me.
It really does.
Let's open some overtime for God's sakes.
Go sits around it just,
I mean if anybody was going to get it,
I get given the nod to cruise cause he,
he,
he definitely seemed to get Cody to fight his fight more and he connected with
some good shots.
But Jesus,
it was so close.
You mean Tj?
Yeah.
What did I say?
Cody?
Cody.
Yeah.
I could just so God damn close if anything can do a draw and then just make them
fight the next fight.
So there's a clear winner.
Dominic landed more like clean shots on Tj,
but TJ landed a lot of shit on him too.
And it hit him with a lot of leg kicks to had him limping teen.
Although he got so,
like you said,
he got so emotional and it's just head hunting for awhile there,
which is where I thought Domic started to win rounds and have to go back and
watch that again.
Me Too.
But flood them.
Remember how watched it twice maybe three times for that.
It was such a God damn close fight.
I remember being surprised at Tj.
Didn't try to finish him with led cakes because Dominic was wobbling so bad.
That guy with my surgery too.
You know what I'm saying?
At all.
Fair in love and war.
Go ahead and kick those knees.
Go Slam that plantar fasciitis.
Yeah,
he was saying after the fight that that's what it was.
It was his feet.
His feet are just fucked up cause that's what we call career.
Well you know what it is.
It's because he came back after a long time off because the surgeries and once
you got in shape,
he had to make up some last time he went nuts.
He went nuts and he tore the punch his feet on here that that she had.
Apparently.
He's like,
so have you ever had it?
No Bro.
I had it for my camp against Mitch reone cause I again,
I've run,
I love to run.
I was doing so much roadwork.
I see that in the mornings was the worst time I'd get up and it would take me 15
minutes just to kind of make my way to the toilet.
Like my foot hurt so goddamn bad.
That wouldn't be a good thing for me today.
Today I don't have 15 minutes today I got,
I got the shits that you'll,
you get like you got about 30 seconds notice.
Yeah,
it's go time.
I feel like the rumble talking about the word,
the fucking horrible.
Like oh Jesus.
Okay.
Can I get a level five?
We go,
yeah.
If you have to wait 50 oh leg lock.
Cause she's a little high.
A little high.
She can't do that.
I mean you got to get a scoot down.
I'm so condescending.
Your car honey.
I'll see what's wrong with that though.
It's rude.
Is it honey?
If I was her really upset at me and
not me,
I'd find it flattering that triangle up,
baby.
Going to lock it up.
Go on sweetie.
Lock it up like of just being a dick.
Come on sweetie.
You think triangle,
sweetie bear.
Glad.
Hook the leg.
What?
We're doing work now.
You've got the arm bar.
Yeah,
she's got good crank cranking.
That girl,
Dude.
She's got both here.
Oh,
she's got that arm?
Yes.
What I'm saying?
That foot's in play.
Then we'll see those photos.
Feeder in play.
It's supposed to hook that leg.
He's supposed to control,
uh,
the position
better.
Who can that legs giant.
Um,
you know,
major people do it two ways.
When you are control someone from a triangle,
do you hook the leg like this?
Do you scoop it around on the outside or do you go underneath it depends,
right where,
where you're at.
Exactly.
I go underneath.
Underneath.
Seems like the move.
Right,
because you can elevate their leg.
Yeah.
Some people don't like that though.
Some people like to just hold onto the leg,
the leg to a rat.
I mean,
you know what man,
whatever the fuck you can.
Yeah,
exactly.
Especially when punches or flying or you're going to cue the battle for whatever
it takes to get that goddamn leg.
It's funny,
like so many people have so many opinions on a unlike hand positions and chokes
and stuff.
It's all fun and games to him.
The bullets are flying,
you know,
I want to learn from that,
that DV ever learned that Gogo choke that I'm talking about the broth.
World choke.
Yeah.
Do you know that choke?
Not like Rothwell does.
Yeah.
His,
his instructor.
Um,
Jamie,
see you get five Ben Rothwell's Jujitsu instructor.
Once he finds he's want to Hickson's guys,
he's a bark problem.
The Hixson apparently this choke that this guy's got.
It's just phenomenal.
What's up with Rothwell?
Did he piss hot or something?
He pissed hot.
I think.
I'm pretty sure.
I feel like you did.
Yeah.
Did any news on jds?
No.
He pissed hot for a diuretic.
This is like,
I mean,
what do we got to do?
You tell your boy that golden snitch.
Just relax a little bit.
Nope,
can't do it.
Louise.
Claudio,
there he goes.
Louise.
Claudio apparently is a master.
That shit.
That shit man showed the big maze Chokan bitches out.
He showed a lot of people that choke and they were like,
what the fuck?
Justi Huh?
Yeah.
I guess it's just somehow or another,
the way he's holding it,
he's going into your neck,
into your throat as a,
as he's choking you with it and it's just,
you know,
it's like the people just develop the finest like application of one technique.
Like they just get it down,
whether it's ads or shipping gas,
their shit.
Did it Rothwell tap out Barnett with that?
Yes,
he did tell.
You know that Shit's legit.
Barnett's as legit as it gets grappa wise.
Yeah.
You surprise him with that shit insane.
And you see when he got,
I'm like,
Josh was like,
yeah,
I'm just like,
God damn.
What are you doing?
Yeah,
it was nasty.
Like he wasn't getting out of that.
And a lot of ways those kind of like old school chokes,
like that's allows shitted Josh Barnett's into,
right.
It's catch wrestling stuff.
Break your neck off.
I like Josh.
Yeah.
How about,
I had
a Goldberg Burgum on the fire and the kid,
you know Goldberg the wrestler and he was,
he's real.
He's like best friends with Brock and I said,
do you think Brock is going to come back?
And he goes,
he was going to till John Piss hot.
Oh my.
I said,
you're breaking my heart over.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
no.
Oh my God.
Right then that,
that fuck up your Saturday.
He thought the fire's coming in and fuck your sat up.
That affect your Saturday.
I can't do this Ryan pm on Saturday.
I literally just went
and I looked at Goulburn.
I said,
get out.
Come on,
get the fuck out.
What in the fuck is wrong?
Crazies that he was going to,
we're going to see that monster again.
What is wrong with the world?
Jesus Christ,
whoever that Meade had is that gave that shit to John.
John's gotta be on Suicide Watch right now.
Sitting there with a fucking one of those shakes.
You know,
they always go,
I fucking worn bro.
I warned my swear we should get a team together,
like navy seal team six and just go fuck him up.
Basically it tainted batch.
You know like I gave him,
I gave him the right stuff.
I took the same shit.
I passed.
Yeah there.
Fuck.
I almost said Dirk Nowitzki.
Maybe they didn't know about the,
maybe they're testing over and over again with the blood test.
See,
I heard it.
The new test out of the urine test is Nash to golden snitch about it,
bro.
He got a direct line to him who I will,
he's going to come on the podcast again after John.
We'd get the thing about John.
Well,
I mean if it times out that way,
if not,
we'll do it before,
but I'm going to have monsoon.
Yeah.
It kind of delayed though to that comes out so we get the real fucking info.
Yeah,
probably a good idea.
It's so depressing to me because it felt like John returning the way he did.
Like that's like a superstar victory.
He handled himself with class and dignity after it was over.
I mean everything about it was amazing.
And then to go from that to Piss and hot,
you're like,
oh no,
I was at universal when I found out.
Chamie texted it to me.
He texted me and I thought you were fucking with me.
I thought it was,
I thought you're trolling is fucking with me.
I just cut off the Harry Potter ride man.
I was feeling good about fuck your day up.
How's the is pretty good.
I say Harry Potter ride was fun.
I thought it,
I thought it was fake news.
Fuck man.
Super fakeness.
Super depressing.
You know what I was thinking about?
Um,
what the so withdrawn being out and then you got common,
right?
Like Connor,
Nate.
Things like looming in the air.
That's like what they got to do next.
These huge money fights on that.
There's not a huge money fight but Connor has changed the game for the better.
Especially if you're the fighter but it's like,
you know with WME he's steering the ship.
Yes.
Like think,
think about it cause he made over cause the numbers coming out.
They're saying it's going to be his paper of all time.
So he made a hundred something million dollars,
right?
Yeah.
So you're telling me if you're kind and you're part of his team,
he didn't go,
Hey,
fight Nate Diaz for how much?
Five.
10 million.
Oh,
and also we need your weird this Reebok and they're gonna pay you $100,000 a
year college.
You're fucking crazy.
Well I,
I'm sure there's non negotiables and one non negotiables.
The Reebok deal,
like you can't get around it,
but what you can do disagree.
Well it seems like he can't get around it right now.
Everybody's wearing Reebok clothes.
Well,
no,
you're,
you can get this.
I'm not saying he's not,
not going to wear Reebok,
but what you have to do it,
you're,
you're playing a different game now.
You're talking about the biggest athlete combat sports and you're not getting
him for the 200,000 you're paying a year.
Oh yeah.
That he can go,
listen,
I'm down to wear Reebok.
It's a different animal now.
Well,
Reebok professionally sponsors him to site.
They do.
Paige vanzant just like they did kinda different and more money.
Yeah.
More,
but not to like think how much he made to just wear those,
you know,
whatever he had on his trunks.
Right.
That's a good point.
You know that fight,
if it really did get six and a half million paper view bys,
like they were talking about Conor making $100 million,
if it got 5 million paper revise,
it got one and a half more than that.
It's like he's super,
that's,
that's up for debate because you know how that came about.
So I think Dana was sitting on,
on that snoop cast or something and uh,
your eyes filming,
right.
And Dana goes,
he didn't think he was being recorded.
And Dana goes 6.5 mil and everyone's like,
damn,
you know,
in the room,
like,
oh damn dog and Snoop's like damn dog.
And then your eye turns on and goes 6.5 million and it shuts the camera off.
But Dana never officially said 6.5 but that's how it got started.
So in Espinosa from showtimes,
like,
uh,
it's going to break the biggest preview numbers all the time,
but we're thinking more around for something.
Oh,
like almost five.
Yeah.
So who's,
who knows the truth and who doesn't?
I Dunno.
I liked to go with Dana on this one.
I would say.
Yeah,
I was crunk I blast it out to you right now online.
It says trending towards 4.6 million.
Oh,
domestic.
Domestic.
Oh well then it's 6.5 c this is my thing with Dana.
He wouldn't just throw that up cause he doesn't wanna look like an idiot.
Well especially with he did official or not.
If he says that to your ion snoop,
he didn't think he was being recorded,
but Dana wasn't just like 6.5 everybody.
Like he's not making that up.
If it's trending towards 4.6 nationwide and America,
that's 100% 2 million more overseas guarantee you that our calls,
it says that,
uh,
it wasn't $100 worldwide either.
No,
it's 25 bucks.
In some countries it's 24 99 or in the UK and Ireland,
you know,
that's interesting.
But still you,
you still the pay everybody's,
it's going to be around 6.5 from what I heard.
It's going to be 6.57 does.
Does the UK have like a history of paper views like we do.
Yeah.
Joshua quite the same.
That was,
that was a pay per view for them over there.
But over here was it's free.
Free.
It was HBO.
Right.
Cause he's not a big as star.
You know,
we like trade a little bit.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
Yeah.
It doesn't make sense.
I just wonder how many people ordered pay per view.
I mean,
you know,
the whole,
the way they watch TVs different there and I don't think they consume as much TV
as we do with flighting.
If Connor Slaton or anything Josh was finding they do.
Yeah.
But I mean like overall England,
I mean,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I don't think they have as many channels as we do.
I don't think they watch as much TV as we did this 2017 so that's not what I'm
saying.
I just don't think that it's a normal part of their day,
the way it is our day.
I don't think people in England wa like well go BBC to find out.
Yeah there is.
But I don't think they watch as much.
Yeah.
I don't think they watch as much TV on a whole as we do.
They have some great shows.
No,
no doubt.
But I don't think they watch as much TV on a whole.
I think that's more of a like a,
it's probably fair to say a problem with our lazy ass.
Yeah.
It's a big problem.
I watch some TV,
they're last.
I'll workout for guts to their own president.
Works well,
works out at all.
Zero watches,
five hours of TV a day.
He's hilarious.
He doesn't believe in bed.
He thinks your body's a battery.
You think Juliet.
So He's,
do you choose?
You only have so many beats.
That's why he looks like he's hilarious.
He's so fat.
I was definitely an unhealthy looking.
This fight to amazing by the way he paying attention at all.
Zero.
Um,
yeah.
But either way I think it's going to break the paper,
your numbers.
So,
but congress changes the dynamics for everyone.
Cause now when you want him to fight again,
you can't have them agree to those old terms.
He's a smart guy.
And if he learned anything from Floyd,
you know when you,
when you fight Floyd,
you're fighting a different animal.
Look at Bruce Buffer.
Could he look more,
more board?
He looks exhausted.
He might've seen too many shows you might've traveled to in the airline.
Miles.
Dude,
look super tired.
He will.
It's Rotterdam.
It's been a long trip.
Probably,
but he's ever the fights man.
Yeah.
You know,
he gets it just does this 22nd things and he's recharging.
It's a mindset thing,
son.
It is.
You gotta be in there.
You gotta be in there watching.
There's rumors that he was going to work the Mayweather McGregor fight,
but then I guess it didn't come to fruition.
Who did it?
Jimmy Lennon Junior,
right?
Yeah,
he's good.
You know what my one complaint about that whole thing is I thought they could
have made the intros way better.
Well,
turn the lights down.
Let me hear the volume of the music.
I met Demi Lavato last night,
which made her,
this lady,
she was at the comedy store.
God dammit,
the one nine.
I'm not there.
She's very nice.
Is She nice?
Very nice.
Um,
but my point is,
uh,
she sang the national anthem.
You never get the national anthem at an MMA fight.
Why do they always do the national anthem at a boxing fight?
Because box is awesome and they appreciate America.
I think UFC has just too many goddamn countries fighting every night.
They can't.
We definitely triangle.
Oh,
you were on the feet,
baby.
Now she's two A's to loose.
She might be able to pull this off to and it doesn't look good here.
Not to wait.
Pop that head out.
You got to grab that foot from the outside.
Just reach around.
Oh no,
she's lost
sakes.
That bones all over.
It's all over.
I says all to go ahead and pass.
Grow.
Yeah,
it's gone.
She can still lock this up.
She's got get used to it.
There you go.
She went right back to it.
Yeah,
but she just grabbed it with her.
The other girl.
The girl on the other side.
You?
Yeah.
Well she's just missing that one crucial step of passing the ankle and getting
down,
locking down on the Shin Bone.
You got a force that step,
but that's like your life depending on it.
Like if you are drowning like the,
to be able to get your foot like this is so big that to not be able to get here.
This should be your whole life's goal is to get ahead of that foot and get on
that Shin.
The girl on top lives to be in a triangle like she just dive in her head in
that.
I feel like so much of what you're seeing when you're seeing an MMA is fatigue
so much like that girl not locking up that triangle right there.
If she was super duper fresh,
like in training,
no adrenaline,
no wait,
cut.
She'd be able to lock that.
I tried going off to know her background.
I would too.
I'm talking shit.
I hear Ya.
Sometimes fatigue,
but I think that most of what they see or try and put the hook tell high she is.
That's awesome.
Punching that groans.
Bloodshed alone on Bluebell.
Yeah,
a little Blue Bell Desk.
But you're,
you're seeing a lot of people just doing what they can do with their body at the
moment.
For sure.
This is what they know.
We'll look at Shankar,
when Brock Lesnar Shane was exhausted.
I've never seen Shane in my life get tapped out from the head arm triangle ever.
Oh,
he was.
He was done.
And those rocks,
you know,
path.
She's given up the deep half.
Oh,
okay.
Steph over.
Oh,
that was so silly.
Shit work though.
Oh my God.
She got to go ahead and crank on the chin.
I think you got a girl.
She's exhausted.
She's going to tap.
She didn't tap gun.
Craig Smith.
Triangle body tracking on sweet body turn.
Come on sweetie.
Body triangle.
Get that squeeze on.
Oh,
she's got that.
She got it.
She's tapping.
Tapping yet.
Watch this.
Go and break that neck like a chicken bone.
I think she's gonna let her do it.
Nope,
it's going pop now she's going to turn it into a hopper in the face turning
maps.
Oh,
keep going.
Don't stop.
Right here.
Right.
You keep going.
You got stop right here.
Keep going.
Oh,
Z.
This is fatigue,
man.
So like in that scramble,
there was no urgency on the bottom.
She was trying to rest.
You cannot do that.
You have to,
when you,
when you get that opportunity,
you got to scramble hard.
Well that's champions.
Don't you know,
they don't rest in the transitions in the scrambles,
they've moving move like you'll get at DC.
John Jones,
there's no fucking or Tj Cody.
There's no rest there.
I talked to chuck about that once could,
Dale was talking about how when you go down to the ground,
he goes,
once you're back touches the ground,
you got to fucking explode like your life depends on,
it was so many guys,
they get down to the ground and they tried to take a break.
They rest and he goes,
you're already done.
If you do that.
He goes,
you can't do that.
And he goes,
once you're back touches the ground,
you've got to fucking explodes.
Nobody ever got a hold of chuck and like,
can I look down this day and age though?
Guys don't really,
you know,
especially on a high level like the top guys,
they don't rest there.
Randy was the only one that ever controlled chuck on the grounds.
Right.
Can I will work for cuts and grab them.
Get to her,
cause she's beating the shit out of.
This is rough.
You might want to stop this fight.
I had stopped this fight.
This girl is taking a tremendous amount.
Stop the fire.
10 seconds.
You stop the fucking fight.
She's not protecting herself.
Jesus.
That girl took a lot of shots,
get her ass whooped.
Jesus.
She took her a lot of shots.
You're on the right.
It's not too excited.
She wasn't protecting herself.
Man.
That's one thing that's interesting,
the difference between boxing and MMA.
You got way more of a chance to get stopped in boxing.
If you're wobbly,
they'll stop the whole fight.
Whereas an MMA,
they'll let shit go on way longer.
Finish him.
Yeah.
They want to see some ga longer like the Conor fight.
I agree with a stop at two but before his experience level against the best of
all time.
But in general,
they're going to let you,
Anthony,
Joshua Klitschko.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
Fuck.
I mean Joshua basically was flat out cold woke.
Fuck us.
Didn't know where he was at.
And this is after he knocked Klitschko down.
I had him on queers street.
Greatest fight ever.
It was pretty much one of them.
Oh my God,
I'm so crunk.
Yeah,
it was pretty God damn fantastic for the British paper view.
According to the promoter.
Wow.
900,000 buys
the record somewhere.
It's somewhere at none of though.
That was the previous one.
That was David.
Hey,
where's the 1.3 million for the live airing of Tyson fury?
This does this quote here.
It says they broke it,
which was the Pacquiao.
Mayweather fight.
But there's no,
I'm looking also for numbers that show official and then it never came out.
Okay,
fine.
Right.
So it's somewhere around 1.5 million for Manny Pacquiao and Floyd Mayweather and
that's just,
it's just an interesting part too though.
I remember seeing some numbers like this for the Mayweather.
Mcgregor fight,
this German TV,
they're like it for free.
I think they're hanging out with 10 million people watching it there or
something like,
well,
it's the same like in Brazil when like cyborg fights or since Silva,
it,
there's no paper view there.
So it's like 90 million people watch it.
Dang.
16 million.
They got 16 million to watch David Haye versus hoody fight.
Who's to say Tyson fury?
Well,
Tyson fury is a very famous guy,
right?
Mary's 20 wasn't that big.
Now he's more famous.
Did you see when he gave like a shout out to fricking,
uh,
what's her name?
The girl,
the other Irish chick.
Sinead O'connor because she's suicidal.
Have you seen that Sinead O'Connor,
like Facebook live,
suicidal from a hotel?
What's she have mental illness?
It's something I would say so yeah.
But then,
uh,
Tyson fury reached out to her because he suffers from it too and was like,
Hey,
call me.
I don't think she's calling him,
but he was like calling me,
you need someone to talk to is going to livestream and banging her pod watches
Tyson periods giant gets 400 pounds.
We got to talk about is everybody keeps saying that you didn't tell the truth
about your interaction with Nate Diaz because they're reading this transcript
that somebody put up on the conversation you had with Nate Diaz where you said,
I think you're off on this.
That's
exactly what I said,
cause he goes,
you're wrong,
you're wrong.
You don't know boxing.
And then I went,
he went rounds and we're going back and forth and the I go,
I think you're off on that.
I think you're off on this or off on that.
And then someone wrote in quotes,
he teed off on you that those words I a in my vocabulary to describe a fight
teed off also.
I would never disrespect Nate like that in his face like that.
That sounds heavy.
Have you ever heard of me doing anything like that?
Like I would never do that and switch to also what kind of bitch move would that
be you too?
I have nothing to do with that.
You find another grown man.
I would never brag.
He teed off on you.
Nothing do with me.
That's disgusting.
That's so gross.
No,
no.
I've never disrespected,
hey,
like,
but so everybody out there that's talking shit,
you're talking shit on a false narrative.
It's like some fake quote that someone,
they might've thought they heard that and that sounded like it was more
salacious.
So they put that in quotes.
It's not what he said.
No,
it's fake news.
Fake news all day.
Yeah.
They wrote their own stuffing.
It's either like they're vying for headlines.
It's like Brendan Schaub talking shit to Nate and pointing down,
you know?
Yeah.
And he's saying,
you know,
people were saying you weren't on as this guy can fucking crack so you can,
he's fun to watch.
Yeah.
He's got a really odd,
uh,
style man,
because look at his last fight,
Brandon thatch.
It was kind of a while ago.
Did he win?
He beat that.
Had some submission.
I already cracked them.
They submitted them.
Oh,
that's right on defeated Bravo from rob.
Rob 11 at,
Oh,
this is going to be a good fight because cr by her design,
I love saying that name is a bad motherfucker.
He's a tough dude.
It's tough as they come.
He's one of those weird dudes that like you put your hand on him to interview
him.
He feels like wood,
like Dan Henderson.
Like he looks like a normal dude,
but he's not.
This is a lot of total noise.
Not Walk Amongst us.
They look like normal dudes that you put your hand on me like hey yeah.
2161 and Rob Wilkinson 11.
Oh Man.
That dime piece picture.
Um,
is this Amanda Liao?
Yeah,
that's going to be a fun fight.
I got to stop doing these things when I would come straight from Yoga class,
my first hot yoga,
all sweaty and they'll put makeup on me,
man.
Oh Jesus.
I forgot how bad this is.
Boom.
I mean it was tough to watch.
Is there ever been like a super fight?
That was that one sided.
A super fight where everybody thought like,
Holy Shit,
I can't believe this is about to go down.
Look at those people shocked and one person makes the other person who like,
they have no business in there and just over and like it just a career ender,
complete total career ender.
Such a bad idea for her to come back.
Well this was a bad idea for it to come back against this fucking power punch
and monster.
She just hits too goddamn hard.
You know,
I talked to cat about it.
She's cat told me cats and gone.
Oh she told me would hit her.
Yes she did.
And she did.
She got hurt and that first round she was finished her and then Amanda gassed
out.
Yeah.
And Kat was telling,
she's like,
nobody,
we're hitting me that hard before.
I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
it'd be a fun fight shift.
Chanko when chef Chanko caught Julianne opinion an arm bar,
I was like torture.
That's opinion.
It was like the next big thing.
And then chip,
take cool,
check this out.
Well she can do so many different things.
The thing about Valentino's she can strike,
she's got worldclass Moitai talking shit and they fought once and it was a super
close fight man.
And people think if it was,
if it was a championship fight with five rounds shift Chanko would have probably
won't cause she started come on late and when rounds she started coming on late.
You know what,
I was super impressed with these two right next to each other like that.
Oh,
that's fake fake news.
That's an edit.
One of the things that I was like super impressed with when,
uh,
when I saw her fight Holly,
Ooh,
look at that.
Touching each other's faces and Tim's when left themselves some timbs young
Jamie.
Well you know what man,
she's Brazilian and she's gay.
She do whatever the fuck she wants.
I agree.
Brought those fucking tims.
I was just super impressed with her ability to control the interactions.
She uses that check,
right hook her,
her uh,
her like footwork and like her technique when she was like,
she basically shut down Holly.
Yeah,
I know.
Which was surprising.
Not Easy to do.
I mean,
I dunno what Holly was going into that fight with the,
she was like on a down like maybe didn't have a good camp.
Maybe it wasn't that her best.
But if you look at how good Holly looked against Jermaine Duran to me,
how the fuck is Germane Duran to me?
Not In the top six cause that she dropped,
she left the weight class.
Yeah,
but she's back now.
No,
she's not.
Yes she is.
No,
she can't be.
She's ranked number nine at like at one.
Uh,
uh,
she's back at one 35.
Oh,
you're fucking right.
So she'd left one 45 dropped out.
That you're right because they're like,
what do we do with this chick?
Well,
it's weird because it's like she abandoned her title,
so shouldn't have to fight Cyborg,
which probably a good move,
but also career suicide because now no one respects you.
Yeah.
Right.
Like I get it.
I don't want him to fight cyborg either.
But gifts camp at least take the ass whooping then cut.
Yeah.
I guess the argument is like,
you know,
she's saying that sort of Cyborgs,
a career cheater that doesn't work because she's passed every test and she's
passed the test now doesn't work.
You can't just keep banking on that.
Especially if you look at the way she fought when she fought Tonya evenger.
You know,
she fought very professionally.
She fought with very good.
She beat the brakes off.
That's the breaks off her and she fought like,
um,
it was intelligent.
Like she was very technical.
The way she pros to fight,
she just tried to Morocco.
I was like,
this is a mature cyborg murder her though for us for sure.
Make it exciting.
But if you,
if you're a Cyborg fan,
you like that cerebral Cyborg,
she'd just be so tough to beat but also be the Mike Tyson of women fighting and
Merker for us.
That's what you're there for.
Hats,
hats off to her.
She just talking about Zombie mom would not help.
How tough is that girl?
She would not go away.
Huh?
So got into.
But I think she also Cyborg.
She caught Cyborg.
Would a couple shots,
a couple of punches.
Not a whole lot on them,
but yeah,
you got to make sure your mind,
your p's and q's and she knew eventually she's going to beat her down.
She had five whole rounds.
But Jermaine stepping away from it like that,
the real shame was Jermaine would have been a fucking very interesting,
fun fight.
Germane.
It's super technical and she's phenomenal striker.
But now Holly comes right on and slide.
That should cause I think Holly won that fight.
I thought one,
I had Holly winning and also uh,
Jermaine also,
you know,
she had some suspect punches after the browns,
like they should pick and points from her side probably won that fight.
So now Karma catching up the way things work out.
Life works out and he got Hollywood cyborg hopefully.
Yeah,
that's going to be interesting.
I thought it's a fight if isn't Holly Holly scheduled for to fight Cyborg if
they scheduled it?
The rumor was Ms Square Garden,
but nothing scheduled yet.
I think that,
you know,
with Jermaine she was,
she came out in the first rounds and controlled it.
She controlled the fight but then she started to slow down.
You know,
and I think part of it,
I mean who the fuck knows could be pressure.
It could be,
you know,
whatever it is.
But that's when Holly clipped her with that question.
Mark kick remedy.
She claimed Dairylea she's Shinder with that.
And then Holly dropped her with a straight left is Jermaine was coming forward,
did the most damage and she got hit late twice,
twice.
I felt he was her fight.
I really do.
And that's why should we should fight Cyborg,
which,
but it pisses me off the best in the world.
She should be two division champion.
She really Shelly.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's dirty man.
It is dirty.
Um,
and then have Jermaine just step away from the title after that.
It's like,
oh come on.
This is crazy.
Some bitch stuff.
They definitely should have taken the point away for the second time.
Definitely 100% that's why the hell should be,
yeah,
I agree.
That alone would be the champ.
And I think,
I just think that like rounds where like Holly flatlander with that head kick
and then dropped her again with that straight left.
I'm like,
those are two big moments in the fight.
The most.
Anybody was hurt in the fight with those moments that should show in the
scorecard.
I don't know what system they were using.
His New York.
Oh,
the oldsters.
It's like,
wait,
what happened?
I missed that.
And then you know,
especially with taking the points away,
cause that was in Vegas or Kelly,
Holly Hollywood have won that fight.
Who'd,
how bout the scorecards for the Connor may are there five hot
Jesus Christ one round.
How crazy is that?
Those are out of your mind.
And Floyd was like,
come on man.
One round.
Come on.
First of all,
Max Kellerman owes you some Dick pics or something.
Doesn't at least a dick pic hasn't had the very least.
He actually,
he actually got regret.
Her will not land a meaningful punch.
We're round.
What?
Are you fucking crazy?
No,
he goes,
he won't land a single punch.
He was just as bad for boxing.
He clipped him with a good left upper cut in the first round.
Gouche and they're like,
Floyd allowed him to do that.
Oh yeah.
If you know anything about Floyd,
he's not allowing.
So a fucking hit him in
the face.
It's so stupid.
Him and Brian Barbarina should have a beach dad bod contest.
Yes.
The two of them cause yes.
Show up on the beach with a fucking six powerful Afghanistan while I was on one
of those fucking fold up aluminum
with the Mesh sack lunches.
Fucking ham sandwiches.
I'm telling you man,
that dude is made out of bricks.
He had so fucking hard and he's,
he's literally like one of the,
like the densest dude's didn't rob six.
Three though.
Tall Dude and 85 it's 25 oh by her design.
I used to fight 70 now he's at fighting an 85 I a small lady.
Fiver.
Yeah man.
Maybe took this fight on short notice.
How tall is he?
Would they say five 11 five 10 if you look with 60 he's built and then think of
Yoel Romero did the same way class.
Well yeah,
doing like that man.
That's how it has to be done.
They didn't really is.
That's the world we live.
It is what?
It is not fair.
It's not occasionally eat lions.
It just just doesn't happen.
It doesn't happen.
Lighting just doesn't work like that.
It just is what it is.
You know that due to place Tyrian Lannister is not going to kick your ass no
matter how much he puts his mind to it.
It's never happening.
It's just not God cr.
That's what a great name can.
I haven't seen him fight at first.
Have her man.
He's been around for a long fucking time.
How old is he?
He looks dirty.
Six has been a 40 it was he 42 Jamie?
I'm a fuck like to every bit of 42
yeah,
I would say he's 36 I'm going to say 37 what is it?
Three 33
whoa.
What's he eating?
Well,
it's like got to change up.
You die at home.
I feel like the international ring girls are kind of killing it.
They're repeating the American ones.
I feel like late.
Are you with the old faithful inn?
My friends.
You're Europe.
I also enjoy them too.
I'm just saying international step in the game up for 53 first round.
52 51 50 they have the clock on the screen,
right?
Yup.
Okay.
Jamie is on the ball.
Jamie gets this.
He'd been locked up and shit.
Making good use that extra 15 pounds.
We had another hiccup on the flight path.
What is he eating?
You're talking about a,
it gets him so big.
Uh,
yeah.
It's like,
imagine it as much as you have to train to be an MMA fighter and he's older.
Sometimes genetics go fuck that.
Hoe.
Getting the dad bod 33 that's not that old.
Oh Shit.
I think it's just wars.
You know,
saw Australia,
maybe Jesus Christ,
man,
relax is the Australian or English.
He's Australian.
Rob Wilkinson,
Australian.
This good,
good striking composure for who Wilkinson.
But bar desire just throws Brexit man.
Yeah,
he's there to scrap.
Dangerous.
Very dangerous guy because he's throwing everything in every shot and if he can
catch you inside the first round,
especially,
you know he's going to hurt you.
You know,
the first round.
So dangerous.
Hell yeah.
It's dangerous.
Especially finding a guy like that.
Yeah,
but he's got to take these breaks.
You know when you sprint like that when you're that guy.
Ooh.
And I hit well a yes,
right.
Like that.
Cause the shorter guy that Rob's fucking wade longer and ranger.
Hey Rob for sure.
Get the job out there though so you keep them back.
There you go.
It's always been his style though.
Borrower design has always been kind of a reserve occur that's 70 though.
It's going to be way more easier than these 85 months or so.
And that Jim Against Luke Rockhold.
Yikes.
Well I can't imagine this is a,
the way class is going to stay in.
I think if I'm looking at his body right here,
he's carrying around a lot of,
oh we just clipped him with that right hand.
He's carrying around a lot of body fat.
I feel like this is probably a short notice fight fight a guests,
but I'm just guessing he's had a long career too so I might just be like,
I'm sick of cutting weight could be right.
I can't perform at my best and dude start getting like kidney problems and weird
shit happening with their body when their,
their bodies is shutting down from the weight loss when that's a kept DC out of
the fucking Olympics.
I know man.
But also like with the weight cut it.
I think it's harder on females.
Yeah,
I hear that.
It's so rough,
man.
I hear that a lot from them.
They don't,
some of them get big and they got to cut weight and with your thyroid and all
that stuff.
I used to take down.
Look,
it's,
it takes it back.
Didn't get the hook in right away though.
Oh,
nice knee to the body and drops down again.
Good timing to the shorter guy down.
He took them down once.
It just didn't get that Hook quick enough.
It says that uh,
crs the only five,
four times in five years.
Wow.
Well I think he had some shoulder surgery.
He has got damn times.
So it sounds like,
I think he had shoulder surgery.
Jamie,
see if you can find that.
Those injuries and setbacks.
It doesn't say which.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure he had shoulder surgery.
It looks like you can tell like he has a scar on the shoulder.
The front of the shoulder can also be,
it could be some latent caveman jeans.
I got some of those.
I got weird patches of hair that Donnie and belong there anymore.
Do you?
Yeah.
For humans,
I feel like guys would lock testosterone.
Have more hair that fair to say?
Yeah.
Not on the top of your head though.
No pens everywhere else.
Like your body.
Yeah.
Like your body is a shitload of here.
Like,
well that's my [inaudible].
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's why I get super scared when I see those super hairy Russians.
Yeah.
They freak me out too.
Like the dudes that like their whole back,
his hair,
just their legs.
I thought I lost good ways.
I looked at shogun like,
well sir,
you have here all over your shoulders.
Yeah.
Chia pets.
That's scary.
Do you know?
Well,
we'll see how it goes for the fucking
wow.
He got the two.
He might have it here.
Uh,
he doesn't know how to get out.
It doesn't know how to get out.
See how it's just strange and you give them that data role,
son.
Oh,
he's okay.
He's okay.
Wow.
He might,
he might get through this.
Wow.
Kevin Tubbs.
He's tough.
He's very tall man.
Probably and flat from Australia to gut.
In Rotterdam,
you get choked out like that.
It's probably a long flight.
Right?
Oh,
naps.
I don't want that either.
Wrestler.
I don't want no part of that.
I want that.
So preposterous throw.
Um,
look up Bruce.
Dom,
Chia have.
Look at that guy.
That was that big giant.
Do the date.
Jay David Haye fought.
How has he and I end game if that's valid.
Yeah.
Holy look at that here.
Yeah,
he's a straight up gorilla.
He ends up,
the only thing he plucks is his eyebrow.
So this is [inaudible].
He's a fuck.
I don't know if that's him.
That's another Harry Rahel.
You get
Russian Harry wrestlers.
I feel,
feel like these dudes have crazy to Sasha on the fucking Harry.
Like a gorilla.
Most of muscle have girls for kids.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
This could just be straight up was that legal signed legal Harry backs.
But I feel like guys a lot to SAS drone.
Not a lot of here.
Harry is fuck chest,
back and shoulders and usually I have girls.
Kind of makes sense.
It's science.
Weird science
dude.
I thought after our last podcast that so many people hit me up about large
Marge,
everyone remembers that bitch.
I wonder if she's dead.
She's gotta be Marge.
Marge.
This was 85.
She was like,
ah,
she's deep in her nineties.
If she's alive,
she might be killing it.
Maybe she has like a podcast.
The large Marge passed away in 88.
Ah,
a couple of years.
Then when she died from coke and whores,
she's got them moving money.
That movie man,
she fucking went Johnny Depp and started buying castles and chin.
I was reading about this chicken South Africa.
She's a student and uh,
they're supposed to put like $100 in her account and instead,
or thousand dollars in her account.
Instead they put a million,
they put $1 million in her account.
And so she went off for like a month,
was just buying clothes and shoes and taking her friends on trips and all that
shit.
And then they found it out and then she screwed.
I spent 60 grand though.
They said,
yeah,
but in South Africa,
that shit is,
that's,
that's like 60 grand.
You're fucking p diddy at gold houses and shit showing up with designer clothes
at school and they're like,
whoa,
what's going on?
Just bought a new iPhone seven Gucci shoes and Shit and tarps.
Yeah.
Paul and out of control showed up in a new kid.
How silly is that new camera with the gold teeth?
Gold fronts.
Skirts,
spinners for teeth.
Oh,
how's that work though?
Cause the banks mess up and you're like,
oh,
fuck it.
I'm going sizzler.
And then they go,
no,
you're not yours money.
It's like you can't fuck up man.
They would sue you for it.
And if they won in court,
then they're just like,
take it from you.
Okay.
But some,
it's not a law or it's not,
or like it's a civil law or something about,
um,
doing the right thing.
Getting money that,
I forget the word,
I just finished reading,
reading it like you're getting it.
Uh,
Africa,
look at it.
What do I gotta return the camera with fucking spinners on it like that.
I own that thing,
man.
Amen.
Did you hear that Nate Diaz wants $20 million for the rematch with Conor s he
and he should get 20 to 30 million.
Do you think that it's,
how many paper view buys?
Do you think that that fight would be worth?
1.5 now.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe more now.
Cause let me ask you this,
Joe.
What slit?
Say Nate fought.
Let's say Nate fights the one of Kevin Lee.
Tony first and in there,
the main event paper view.
How many papers you buys as Nate Diaz do without Conner?
Well not as many.
Not even close.
Not even close,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's a big kind of thing.
But the big fight for Conor is Nate.
Like if Connor fought Kevin Lee,
how many pay views would he get you again?
He might.
You're right,
you're right.
You're right.
You look up.
All Congress writes,
he's never done less than a million ever.
You're right.
So he's the Floyd Mayweather fight MMA.
Now we freeze.
God dammit.
Fipass son of a bitch.
Conspiracy theory.
Snoop Casanova's Fitch.
It's snoop cast.
Okay.
They fucked us.
We're,
we're sitting here frozen out later.
We will.
Oh my God.
Oh,
we're back.
We're back in low.
Done.
No,
it's dead.
It's dead again.
We've got a streaming issue.
Some shit is going down or there's such a demand for this.
It's fucked up like Mayweather.
Mcgregor.
They don't know how to handle the overload.
They only expected 50 people and they got a hundred.
They'll how dare you.
Yeah,
this is ridiculous.
Um,
um,
yeah,
but I think Nate,
rightfully so.
She gets that fights can be the biggest paper of all time.
I really do.
I think the trilogies you can be because of for MMA frame may for him and may
because of commerce.
Right?
He's bigger than ever.
Biggest combat sports.
That's a long flight back to Australia,
like going out like this kid's tough man.
Oh,
he's getting rock 'em sock.
'Em robots.
I stop it now.
It's close.
Certainly close.
Oh,
hold up.
When you're sitting Indian style,
probably stop it now,
man.
He's getting up.
Getting up with his ass.
What?
Go ahead and stop it.
Stop it now.
Stop it.
Stop.
Stop the fucking fight.
Come on,
look,
look at,
Oh my God.
Damn it.
Like he didn't need that.
I mean the referee collided with him and hurt him.
He the head where the head bottom.
Wow.
She are shut off to Afghanistan.
He the dude can crack man.
So I'm saying the dude can look forward to seeing them fight that guy team the
white 2018 you don't want to do coke with that guy with the white suit or you do
or look at all those people.
I do coke with that poor guy.
The ref gave,
not cut
but with Nate I think that the fight that,
that's the thing with this fight and that's why I don't think you're gonna see
it happen very soon cause both Nate and Connor realize how much power they have
and you can't just go from with the old rules anymore.
They liked the Connor is changed the dynamics of the fight game for the better
for the fighters.
It's a great thing.
It is a great thing.
I just wonder like how much knee can actually get.
Definitely because what they say,
I think report said between the two fights,
he made around 2.5 million to fight him twice.
Now he made 2 million plus to fight him both times.
Both Times.
So it's 4 million.
So 4 million total.
That's what I'm reading.
I did not talk to Nate.
I did not talk.
I read this,
so I thought I made two maybe.
Yeah,
you might be right.
Maybe I miss quoted that.
So maybe it's two and two or two and a half.
Two and a half.
Either way.
So say made 4 million.
There's no way in the world you can say,
hey Nate,
fight Conor and the biggest fight of all time trilogy,
Connor's going to get 40 million during get two and a half again.
There's no way that happens.
Both guys realize the magnitude of this fight and he made $4 million in a year.
So like how much money does he have leftover?
You probably got $1 million plus just sitting in the bank doing nothing.
So what do you know what I'm saying?
So the dynamics have shifted towards the fighters for first time.
Now if you the UFC,
how do you make this work with Conor?
Because he's not fighting guys anymore for five 10 million.
You can't,
when you have over a hundred million dollars in the bank and the biggest star of
all time,
what do you think the most common made in the UFC fighters?
10 Mil Pri you think so 10 12 Mil Max.
So now you think he can get like probably like 30 at least right at leap ends on
how many papers if you buy otherwise why are you doing it?
What if he gets like,
what if Nate and Connor gets 3 million paid reviews?
It's not out of the question.
It's not,
it's a stretch when I stretch.
But if Nate can talk the right amount of Shit,
you know,
and people get excited about,
honestly right now for Connor,
what else is there that's even close?
The first fight in MMA,
what else do you call it?
The only argument is you can say commerce.
The only draw.
He can fight Billy from Afghanistan and still get 2 million paper.
You buys or breaking Millie.
You let Conor fight Pauline,
Mylan,
Naji and Dublin.
See if I'm Connor and I have McGregor promotions,
I'm going,
wait a second,
I'm going to fight this monster.
Nate Diaz.
You want to pay me 10 million?
You wear Reeboks or I'm just going to go to Dublin.
Me and he sell this 70,000 state amount.
I'm just gonna take all of it.
You have to.
He goes,
Whoa,
hey,
hey chill.
He's still got it.
Some sort of a,
they must have all checks coming up.
They have some sort of a deal for boxing too.
You know they have the zoo for boxing shirt that Dana was wearing.
It might be putting my skeptical hip eyes like the shirt and I'd rock get myself
cause like zoo funds.
However Mcgregor promotions I'd assume as commerce thing.
Really.
You think he's in cahoots with the,
with the UFC?
I would think he has to be.
I don't think he would make a deal with McGregor promotions.
I think you made a deal with what he's saying.
You can buy that superblock zoo for boxing tee shirt.
25 bucks.
Why does it say Dana White Zoo for boxing?
Ti Does Dana white come with it?
It's a false average picture of him.
This is fake news.
I,
I'd rock that button.
Hey,
by the way,
um,
I would imagine you have some sort of a deal.
Okay.
So let's say you have a deal.
Think about this Joe.
So let's say Connor and Dana have a deal with the McGregor promotions and like,
I,
your next fight,
we're going to cope,
promote with you.
Well,
how's that gonna work now?
So then you're,
you're it this huge fight and Nate's like,
hold up if he's gonna make all this money that I can,
I know where we're in cahoots with him.
Do you mean for the UFC?
Yeah.
No,
I don't think he'll cope.
Promote for the UFC.
I don't think so.
No.
But I think it would cope.
Promote if you had a Pauline Mala Naji boxing match and doable and in fucking
Dublin gammy brand.
Do you see that?
You've been,
I want to see everything,
Dude.
I want to see snails race.
It's Hillary takers.
The fight is DNA Diaz fight.
That's the fight.
The fight,
but is it the fight as far as a business?
Cause if Collin learned anything from Floyd,
you know that when you fight,
Floyd Floyd is the businessman.
He's zone promoted,
he's everything.
Connor has his own promotional.
Now he's the businessman now.
So Connor's going,
listen,
what are we doing here?
What do you guys want to do?
Maybe if the UFC contract that Connor has runs out,
maybe they make some new crazy,
ridiculously lucrative.
That contract doesn't matter if it's out or not because the game has changed.
Hmm,
interesting.
Yeah,
you don't,
there's no way you would keep going with that current contract and the way by
Mcgregor sports and entertainment limited.
The notorious Conor McGregor and notorious.
Why did you pull that up?
I don't give a fuck.
This is a company that it's officially exists and they own these things and it's
all Connor stuff.
Yeah,
it's registered in his name.
Not mean.
That could be like a tee shirt company.
It could be,
but it's all these dick,
I don't know.
Whatever.
I'm sure he's got something.
I mean,
must have some sort of a,
but also Dana White.
I don't know about the guys that dummy with Dana White's not stupid enough to
let Connor do all this and not be involved in it.
He's not even really sure it make your own thing,
man.
Do your thing,
buddy.
There's no way.
Hm.
Interesting.
I know either way,
whatever he does and interesting.
I know.
I would like to see him box Paul while Nate just keeps eating tacos and going to
Cabo doing tequila shots.
I really like the fights going to go away.
It's not to go away.
I disagree.
Yeah.
Fights around the year that you think they it.
So,
I don't know,
man.
I think it,
if Nate wants to just chill and just train and have a good time.
The fights there in a year.
I don't think so.
I think if Connor stays active,
I guess with Nate,
what's up?
How are you going to stay in the limelight?
Like,
yeah,
he's fighting Nate Diaz again.
Uh,
they fought over two years ago called the heights,
not there.
Pauline Mala Naji in a boxing match in Dublin,
Ireland.
Yeah.
Martez legit possibility to get a win over a two time world champ.
World champion in the second boxing fight ever to boxing fights.
Ever two world champion [inaudible] Bank.
[inaudible] months on bowling.
How many say how much balls?
Stupid.
How much money do you think you would get for that fight though?
Not nearly as many more money than you'd get.
Fight Nate ATS with a tougher challenge.
Right?
So like what do you think the paper view would be for a polyman Naji fight?
What did even be a million bars?
For sure.
He thinks whatever con.
See,
that's the thing.
Connor Connor could play fucking in a slippery softball game right now.
A lot of people are going to buy that bitch.
You know what I'm saying?
So him fighting Pauli and there's all this heat.
People were like,
God,
he did well against Floyd.
We could see him being poly.
I would say at least a million.
And then if it's your own promotion,
what do you make?
30 right?
30 40 Mil,
right?
Hmm.
Interesting.
Bring your balls,
Connor,
please bring your boss.
Now Paul enlist.
Everyone knows that.
Like Polly when,
how Paul,
he's talking shit to all the UFC.
Well,
he should shut the fuck up because if you wanted to have a UFC fight,
he can go over there and get his brain kicked in.
Yeah.
You don't want them to stop talking.
You're a boxer.
You're very good boxer.
Just shut your mouth.
Just just go after.
There's literally a million people in the world that could grab you and strangle
the life out of you and there's not a goddamn thing you can do about it.
Correct.
Sorry Dude.
Like the UFC is not what you want to and you just don't get it.
Don't talk shit.
You will.
It will give you a wrestler and he will punch your fucking face into pulp.
Well,
he's not a goddamn thing you can do about it.
No,
not a goddamn thing.
Think he went towards Tony Ferguson alleyway was,
he's thick right now,
but what's his weight class like?
45 45 47 yeah.
How about you?
You give him Ricardo Lopez.
How about you give all your Rodriguez?
How about that?
I mean,
yeah.
You know what that,
God.
Look at them.
Give him a guy that's not the top of the food.
Don't give him Frankie Edgar.
Don't give him Josie.
All Doe.
You don't need to do that.
You know who he could beat up though?
Oh,
cm punk.
He'd start Sam pond.
Probably.
Fuck.
See Him upper cut the fuck does.
Imagine what Max Holloway would do.
The polyman algae in an MMA fight.
Just imagine,
just trying to just try to wrap your head around with the kind of ass fucking,
I think.
I think Max when Adam on Twitter,
like they [inaudible] would literally kill him.
He,
if he wanted to monitor,
if you want to literally kill him,
I mean,
so would cub Swanson.
So with a lot of guys,
they just,
what they do in a boxing match,
again,
not so good.
Not so good.
Max has the best shot.
I think Max has amazing footwork and he's a good striker.
Very,
very good.
Striker is an excellent time and good discipline.
And his endurance is phenomenal.
Cody Garbrandt and might have something to say.
Even at 45 you'd come and fight Polly.
It'd be interesting.
Be Interesting.
But Manoj,
he's a legit world champion pro boxer and he's just fucking smart dude.
He's a very smart guy.
He's one of the best analysts in the game.
Like he probably doesn't need to do all this.
Yeah,
well that was one of the things that people were super concerned about.
Him sparring with Connor.
Like he did two 12 round sparring matches with Connor and Connor.
He did a eight round and 12 round one round two him and Connor was,
you know,
landing some,
obviously some fucking hard shots.
Just one.
What we know when we definitely saw that one straight left,
the fucking climbed them.
That was right dead center in the Mug.
And you see the sparks fly.
But also to Paulie's defense.
This was telling Paula like,
dude,
let's say I'm retired.
Let's say Cain Velasquez was a cake shop.
I need you to help me train me.
I need you to come help.
Give me some rounds.
That's not a free ride right there.
That punch.
Fuck no,
that's not a free ride.
That is nice face.
We can refer to it.
That is your face getting crushed.
But here's the thing,
if I,
if I got off the plane,
even from La to San Jose and Cain wants some rounds,
it king goes,
hey bro,
I need you to go five fives.
That ain't happening.
I'm here to help.
You Ain't know it.
DME,
five fives,
one round cell on the side and coaching.
There's a lot of ego shit going on there.
I think Conner's team brought Paulien to fuck him up.
That's the only reason to go.
If he does fuck him up were blasted out there.
Cause the cell,
the fight more.
Yeah.
And that was the other thing they said about that is like he Paulie's like you'd
never go 12 rounds like that.
He's like,
you never really heard of lying and go 12 rounds.
Even in MMA,
I've not heard of someone getting off the plane going five fives.
What basically gave him a practice fight.
That's it.
And it was,
it was smarter Commerce Park because confidence builder,
it also solidified him shit that mother fucker can unbox a little bit and then
Dana blasts it out.
You know,
I think it was good.
It was very smart.
Obviously I see it worked.
Obviously it worked.
Yeah.
Six and a half.
My mom pay per view buys shoes or balls.
You've created an animal so you've paid an animal.
If DFC the hammer,
the got to what else the fuck they have.
What else do they have?
Strew verse go,
Hello.
I want to see the full video.
I want to give.
He is full.
Do you can't see the full video.
You probably could get it and watch it but don't blast up until,
cause if you do that but then you don't have a fight in Dublin Todd.
Everybody.
Oh Man.
You know what I'm saying?
What?
It was like you can't cause let's say Connor starched him for 12 rounds.
Well then that fucks up the paper.
You buy it then we're like course he's going to beat him bullet.
If he didn't.
What if Paul is telling the truth?
Would if Paulista getting the most of them.
See that's why we want this debate.
So you buy the paper view.
If you're an ass kicking,
I'll give you a Tuesday.
That ass kicking.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
you can't that tapes out there,
but you can't release it because going gonna fuck up the fight.
Maybe you see when the security guards were getting in his face,
it's like,
relax dude,
I'm a fighter.
Yeah.
He goes,
come on,
I'm a fighter.
They got kicked him out.
What the fuck you,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
It's like I'm trying to hype up a fight.
Then palm scan of fight during the,
uh,
when we're doing a pre show,
because the fans were just fucking relentless.
The Irish fans were just harassing them and then the guy goes,
Paulie,
I'll kick your ass worse than Conor Mcgregor did.
And then finally Paul,
he goes,
fuck this,
take this things off.
Goes at them.
And so then,
uh,
Brian,
it gets between them,
the comp Tia that with the shaved head.
And so he's like,
no,
please don't do this.
And the guys I do,
so I'm might give you a worse beating him McGregor did in the,
you know,
his Irish accent,
poly can get,
don't buy your spot,
spit on him.
And then it was chaos.
Scary.
Scary for sure.
Again,
security earlier in that though,
I think about Pauline,
he's not scary looking.
So you feel like if there's a pro world champion boxer,
you talk shit to,
that might be the guy hat,
right?
Until you get fucking blasted in the face.
But you know what I mean?
Like there's certain people who is that guy?
That's Pauley and then that's his uh,
commerce manager.
Oh,
but there's like certain,
there's Connor said,
gentlemen,
we're businessman here and fucking business when,
hey,
this is the,
this is the shitty thing.
If you're Paul,
and this is,
this is the Internet Nazi Polly's bring the upon himself.
But if you met Paul,
he's a great fucking dude.
I like guy.
He's a great guy,
but he's just,
he's hanging himself.
Cause I told Paul,
I went,
Dude,
you're responding to these trolls and you're telling you it from MMAS world.
They fucking hate you,
man.
He fucked up when he wore the double diamond earrings.
Studs.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I disagree.
See,
I like the Double Diamond Jersey shoreline.
It's not,
it's not 2001.
You can't do that anymore.
Maybe where he's from.
He had fucking Brooklyn.
They just own that shit rocking from Bensonhurst,
right?
Mobile Nigee Hey,
they got to go straight or yeah,
but who's got the blues?
I am fucking,
what about the linguine?
Vom Go lay in MMA,
man.
They're just murdering.
Puts too much garlic in the sauce.
Yeah.
Paulie's be easy with the fuck.
Hey Dude,
look at this size.
It's true of walking around the cage.
It's like the cages up to his navel,
but also kids cage.
How the fuck did no one put a basketball in your hand?
Well,
do you hate money?
He's a Holland guy from Holland.
They don't even know what basketball is until they come over here to fucking
Google that shit.
It's nice.
It's true.
Taking you out of a Colorado making you play cricket.
Yeah.
I wish someone doing,
mate.
We need a quick,
it's star is seen as you're done.
Good breeding in Mexico.
Come on over and pay meeting your Mexico.
Everyone who plays cricket comes from a football background.
English,
football.
We don't hit each other.
Did he need someone who plays cricket?
Who's more physical?
He,
this homeboy doesn't get enough credit.
Timeout.
M One world champion [inaudible] world champion Jack.
He's a tough guy.
Ballot tour literally cannot hold a heavyweight champion.
Like when was the last time you even thought about the head look at him.
He bounced.
That's what I'm saying.
They can't hold them.
That's why I want Roy Nelson,
Bobby Lashley world title fight or they have to an Indian reservation.
I don't give a fuck what you do.
They have to do.
I want to buy,
but you know why no,
I get ya.
You know what I'm saying?
All natural and also all day.
Why not have fade or material and for a world title fight,
so at least there's a belt,
right?
Well fade or you know,
in Mitre on was a changing of the guard for sure.
Mitchell and knocking out fade or is basically okay.
This,
this ride's over.
It's essentially over.
If he wants to keep doing it,
he can get home until you know for sure.
But that's not American fence.
But like the people in the know that Mela Dano fight.
You're right.
Let's go over,
send me Schiltz old school.
So he's training with semi Shell.
That's a good sign.
He was trading southern Cali for awhile.
A man,
he's a monster.
Good tall 15 first round finishes.
Last fight.
He beat Roy Nelson.
Did he?
Yeah.
That's when Roy was like,
all right.
See you man.
Went to bell door.
That's what happened.
It was a decision.
Uh,
Roy who was a free,
yeah,
he be beat.
Really bad decision.
But then Royce contract was up and he went with belt.
Wow.
Can't blame him.
He's always had words with Dana.
You know,
everybody's always got back and forth.
Yeah.
I can't blame them.
It's good move for Roy.
It's a good move for a lot of guys.
You know what's a good fucking fight coming up is a Paul Daley is fighting a
Lorens Larkin.
That's a great fight.
It's a very good fight.
You know,
I mean daily had that real close fight with um,
the uh,
Beltour champ fucks is murked by Roy MacDonald daily.
Got Yes.
Dale taken down and then,
uh,
Lima,
Douglas Lema.
Oh,
you're talking about Larkin.
Yay.
Blocking had a real good fight with Lena.
Lucky and got hurt in that fight.
But yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
I feel like it's very possible that Roy Mcdonald's the best to wait on the
planet.
He is,
he beat Woodley.
Woodley is our champ and he looked so god damn technical part.
She what Roy said about,
uh,
Robbie Lawler?
No,
he was doing like a reddit Q and a or Facebook Q and a and then went,
hey,
um,
do you think uh,
Lawler was on steroids when you fought him?
And it wasn't like,
Eh,
maybe he was like,
I'm convinced to you us.
Whoa.
I know.
Goddamn.
Damn.
Why?
Why's he convinced?
I don't know.
You'd have to ask,
but Robbie's always been like that.
He's always been like super resilient.
Robbie Lawler for God sakes.
Yeah.
I have no idea for what it is.
He didn't look any different than he's ever looked right.
It always looks the same.
I don't know why you believe wagons cowboy.
I don't know what to believe.
All right.
I know right after that.
Who knows.
I was just like,
who knows where we're like,
gala kind of makes sense now.
I was putting all my Easter bunny chips in the Dick Pills basket,
not me.
I was like ended in half a maybe like a girl cheats on you.
Just forget about it.
Close my eyes and go to sleep and hope and to wake up and I know it's real.
I know they're all natural.
He's just murking everybody.
Yeah.
Robby looked exactly the same when he fought cowboy and he fought the same way
too.
Like the third round was a rough round for cowboy.
He was coming on strong.
Robby was coming on strong.
Right.
We took the second round off.
He took the second one office and the third room was a rough round for cowboy.
Yeah.
Taking it to have them powered body shots.
Good fight though.
Very nice.
I love Calvin.
Calvin got robbed like,
Nah,
actually had Robbie winning that one.
One in three.
If it wasn't a draw,
I would think that you,
I like going towards the guy who's winning the fight and the last round to the
way pride used to do it.
Definitely won the first round.
Definitely when the third round I didn't,
I didn't have it as a draw and a segment.
It's not a 10,
eight and this is someone who's biased is fucked.
We're towel boy.
I was like,
God,
God dammit cowboy.
I agree.
Was that fight?
Um,
under the new rules?
It was,
right?
Sure was.
Yes.
Oh God.
Damn.
Everybody's gotta be on these Goddamn new rules.
How tall are these two?
This is the main event and write and we paid attention to three minutes of the
last fights.
Yeah.
A couple of Dad Bod,
the horrible triangle attempts by the checks and you kept calling them sweetie,
honey,
come on honey.
I'm like,
come on Sweetie Pie.
Come on.
Qt
couple tall boys here.
Super Tall.
You got it made.
You got a good point about that.
You don't have my car.
The international fuck go around.
EXOTICA treasons bump bump on it.
That guy's got a total Norman Rockwell haircut.
It could be in a soda shop somewhere.
Talking to a little kid with his dog.
God Damn stroop has on those giant basketball shorts.
Got True.
She wasn't finding a long time.
It's been a while where it's fucking hard.
Stop for a second.
Yeah.
He has like some serious problems,
right?
We have to have heart surgery man.
Then they thought he's done surgery.
Yeah,
they had to put something in his heart.
He's straight up heart surgery.
So yes.
Holy Shit.
I thought it was just like,
uh,
like uh,
some sort of an illness that,
you know,
and I feel like you'd have some sort of surgery scar.
I don't see it over his heart and my fake news,
Jamie,
sometimes they go into the armpit when they do certain surgeries for the heart.
They go in through your armpit and through the sidewall of your body.
Oh,
I,
they don't have to open your chest.
And I'd be writing cause he,
I know he had some serious shit going on cause we had the same manager at the
time.
Oh neat.
And everybody's supposed to fight Mitch reone that upkept might land one of
these times.
You know what's interesting is Volkov.
It's like one of the few guys that he's ever fought that's pretty close to him
and the reach department.
Travis Browne,
I'm gonna Trash Brown said,
oh you're tall.
Cool suit,
ran punch skyscraper.
That was amazing.
Amazing.
One of the best knockouts ever.
You might have a voided surgery.
Might've avoided it.
How did he do that?
Because you were in the you'll one lamb fight cause he had to do a get to do
something about it because you'll see was like so much of a risk.
Yeah.
He had some sneaky,
great day putting the rape choke on against the cage.
How many times a dude's run into those guys?
The cameras.
I've seen it happen once.
Had a lot,
but these guys are so tall as Cameron,
better to have their head on a swivel.
Also powerful.
Volkov has a sting ray tattoo on his back.
Like marijuana.
That's a marijuana tattoo.
Yeah,
you're welcome.
Oh Man.
What a great movies.
A good movie,
man.
Fuck the rock.
God came,
they I get more talented bad motherfucker.
Oh,
I can see struve on the ground.
Those trouble that motherfuckers guard is crazy.
Hmm.
Modified workout regimen,
dietary changes and pressure medication.
That's the word regimen.
That's one word that I really don't like.
Saying blood pressure medication.
Listen.
Nope.
Oh,
she's out of pillows talking about truck cracked on upper cuts landing dubber
cuts trouble.
Oh.
Um,
I'd be worried about Strube when the going gets rough in this fight,
he has to undergo another cardio vascular examination within six months in order
to maintain eligibility.
That's interesting.
It's true.
We'll have her be required to undergo an to Oh,
Gotcha.
Interesting.
Well you know,
people that are really that tall,
they a lot of times have problems with their heart.
Apparently.
It's just super difficult for your heart.
Great Dane got say to pump blood through all that tissue now named the tallest
Grandpa,
you know,
go.
They're all dead.
Yeah.
It's a real bummer.
But there are some basketball players who've gone over this that are still
really tall.
Have we got over this?
Yeah.
Jamie and I have,
you know,
kids Posi you got to get to the bottom,
get excited about and get those texts.
Got.
But when you're older it's tough.
Like graphene.
She B 12 shots,
those dick pills.
Who's the oldest guy that gets laid on a regular basis?
Hugh Hefner still laying it down as he though to those young Izzy.
I know.
Take pictures of the smoking jacket on and taking naps.
Well first.
Yeah.
All right.
That uppercuts landing,
man.
I'll tell you how the fuck has up not tell all book come out about him.
Just,
you know,
just having limp dick all the time and all these three hot chicks and just the
shit he goes through to get it up and like come on half.
He's got an oil drum filled.
If I aggravate,
he's taking fucking shoot him down like peanut m and m's is that wilt
Chamberlain but he's dead
for awhile.
Uh,
he didn't live that long,
man.
That's not that long.
That old?
Nah,
take game.
Still strong at 63 63 he died.
Yeah.
Whoa.
How old a Hugh Hefner and he's,
he's,
that's his thing.
Dick and girls.
But I feel like it's all a lie.
Like they're all like,
yeah,
just taking a nap.
We'll chill here and while we make noises just pays.
Well,
Graham crackers and shit.
Yeah,
his grandpa Liz bed.
Can't believe it's going down in that room.
He's snoring and farting.
Meanwhile,
just a soundtrack.
Kimchi farts.
Farts.
Smell like tobacco pipe.
Sleep.
Fuck.
Oh fuck.
Coughs on top here.
Dropping them hammers.
Yeah.
He's not fucking anyone who might be.
It could just be like the ultimate ladies.
Man.
What is the oldest living?
A basketball player.
A pro basketball player.
It wasn't Bill Russell.
Fairly old.
How old is he?
I saw Clyde Drexler and Vegas duty alone.
Hammering him 83 bill Russell's 83 that's amazing.
And he's a tall dude,
right?
Isn't even fuck.
He's like six something.
Six 10 or something.
That's amazing that he's that healthy at that age.
Eight six ten six 10 10 Jesus.
That's like crazy.
He's fucked up.
Wow.
They're both fucked up though.
Yeah.
Big Car.
Big.
No,
it was really interesting.
Race.
Ooh,
got super interesting race.
I'm not mad at that too.
I celebrate sting ray myself.
Wonder why?
Because he's a stinger.
Yeah.
Look at Bill Russell 83 titles.
I can just tell by looking at him.
He's not take anyone down.
You know it's not the shoulders posture.
Yeah,
exactly.
It looks sad.
Wow.
Struve Katyn off here.
What's the upper cut?
Boom.
There it is.
It keeps sneaking over that left arm,
dude.
That knees and what condom that Greg glancing knee.
You don't want to be it against truth.
He was like married to a dime piece still though.
He finally,
he finally settled down,
lift up and he also sold the mansion.
You know that be like still lives in like the backhouse something.
Well he had some weird deal like you're trying to sell the mansion for like 200
million bucks,
but he had to live there.
That was like part of the deal.
I don't know if he actually sold it.
I think he did.
Someone Bob's a cake can chill in the back.
Backpage.
This is weird.
I'm going to,
I'm buying.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'll do that and as soon as we can to get your old ass out.
Well you got to realize like how much time does he have left?
Like,
how much can they live?
10 years.
How old is he?
Hugh turned 90 last year.
He's solid.
Five years left is 29 29 let me see.
First of all,
he's 90 she's two she's 29 yeah.
Well she's 30 this year.
Congratulations.
Good for you girl.
You won the lotto.
You bad person.
You're a whore.
She's fine,
dude.
Yeah,
I'm not mad at her.
my bad.
Leave her alone.
No,
not matter girl.
Good God.
Those are totally real tests too by the way.
My go.
Gorgeous body.
You have out kicked your coverage.
Old Man.
Without a doubt.
She is.
What'd you bring up the best picture of all time.
You get a full bar?
No,
she's hot dude.
She she smokes.
Well man,
the one you brought up was great.
Okay,
so we can go belong in the,
they're long in the face.
How dare you?
She's 30 years old.
You son of a dude.
She's hot there though.
You are a mean person.
A pretty there.
Ooh He did for you here.
She's more than hot enough.
I wonder if they have like an arrangement,
meaning like of her trainer comes over and just runs trains on her
with his fucking apprentice.
I've got a couple of friends coming over.
Hey,
we're gonna,
we're gonna do a little workout relationship.
Yeah,
I think you got to you t there's no way.
If,
if his heart is a normal heart,
he can fuck more than once a month.
You're talking about Hugh Hefner.
You're talking about Hugh half,
not the legend.
This is what he does,
bro.
Oh Shit.
I poke,
come on.
Dammit.
This
look at his old basic lives.
Those were the basic dates.
Free got fucking rich.
And how many people had,
he had one of them.
It was flying a plane when he met her.
Look,
she was fucking,
that's a captain's hat.
The fuck is he doing?
It's tilted to the side and from World War One and shit.
That's what he's doing.
He was like getting 49 he was ahead of the game when it comes to tilting your
hat sideways.
Oh yeah,
that's a poker right?
A hundred percent dude.
How bout uh,
cause we remember the yet the TV show we had the three girls I've slept with
over a thousand women.
Yes.
Have,
I mean who's that one?
Oh,
to say,
tell all got she's sucking.
Yeah,
but here's the thing.
No one's reading those books.
You're right.
You know what?
When you're right,
you're right.
The fuck out of here.
When he looks like he looks like a mannequin there.
He looks like shit though.
He's been throwing Dick for a,
but he's also probably had some super boring conversations with these checks for
a long was that Steve talked to 23 year old.
You want to ram your head in the Goddamn ground after meanwhile he's marrying
these checks.
He's paying a price,
bro.
He is.
I think it's like part of like what's valuable for his brain's a well read guy.
You know,
like he's not,
oh,
there's that uptight.
He's not a moron.
Yeah.
This is a fucking good fight,
man.
Great fight.
Five rounds.
Jesus Christ.
They're super bloody.
Yeah.
This is the second
or the third.
This is the third boy.
That cheekbones fucked up on Volkov.
He got his last divorce cause his wife was unfaithful.
Son of a bitch.
Oh,
how dare you filed for divorce and says his wife was the unfaithful one.
C those are you bitches.
I was talking about the ones from the playhouse.
One Ms. Oh shit.
He's landing on him early in the relationship.
God,
how are you going to cheat on Hugh?
You send them a patch air sheet.
This is my thing though.
Let's say,
could you,
when I was a single man,
I dated a girl who was friends with Hugh.
Could you marry a girl who dated Hugh Hefner?
It's kind of a red flag.
Yeah,
it seems like it'd be an issue,
right?
Yeah.
It would come up if she ever talked any crazy shit,
he'd be like [inaudible] what would you say?
Yeah,
it'd be days at a hundred year old man.
And why did she do that?
To be that magazine in 2016 are you shitting me?
No one reads magazines either.
You're dumb bitch.
Maybe she did it for the experience.
Yeah.
Maybe just didn't like,
you know,
one of those bucket list things.
Maybe just has a strong take game to jelly.
Forget about that.
Right to Hefner for a retro,
right.
Maybe a big Ole summer sausage for a deck.
Yeah,
a giant didn't you got to think that if you're a guy like you have nerd like all
these years of doing this,
all these years of banging chicks.
All right.
It's got to get boring after awhile.
Super born.
So you start fucking dude's
like,
what do you do after awhile?
When did Hugh Hefner?
Um,
I don't know.
I think he like plays backgammon or something.
He has a bunch of kids though.
Yeah,
it could of gang kids.
The magazine tried to have a no naked girls in it.
How for about a year.
How dare you?
Oh yeah.
Let me get my fucking playboy subscription because I want to know about the
politics one.
Are you guys doing for important to read articles?
Brendan?
Oh,
this is a good fucking fight,
man.
Good.
How's the leg kicks night full carb with some solid technique.
Well put.
So struve Oh nice.
Neither.
Bonnie
struve is not a spring chicken,
but he's been around for a long time.
He's been fine for a long time.
I'm thinking about that.
Travis Browne basically out of the picture now.
Roy kind of,
um,
think about,
he fought Pat Barry.
He fought a chip.
Everybody.
Yeah,
he's been around for a long fucking time.
So it was Travis Browne done.
I don't know.
He's what?
He's lost five of last six or six other,
said no shit.
You know.
Uh,
Josh Barnett was super impressed with them in preparation for this last fight.
That Russian dude put the squeeze on them then it doesn't matter though,
because when you lose five out of six,
you know,
like,
we don't care what you're doing.
Training.
He didn't look,
I mean he looked good in the beginning,
in the beginning of looked good.
It's moving around,
but he didn't look like,
you know,
he doesn't look like vintage Travis Brown.
I feel like he needs to go back to Albuquerque,
but maybe you just didn't want to do anymore.
That's positive.
The other thing.
Rhonda got married.
Maybe just,
yeah,
maybe it's just time to move on,
which isn't a bad thing.
Like No.
Sometimes we were,
wants these guys to keep fighting,
but maybe there's more form out there that he's a good guy too.
That's the other thing.
The bad thing is when you don't move on and you keep fighting and you don't want
to preach.
Who needed a body?
Wolkoff
turning on
lazy side.
Tick.
I gotta Piss so hard to it.
Let it go.
This podcast has been brought to you by life and his gentlemen,
the smooth,
sweet,
relaxing experiences of life.
It's a good fight so far,
Jamie and join us.
Yes.
These two.
These are huge.
Yeah,
they're giant Stephan's troops,
seven feet tall and this guy is like not quite as tall as him,
but he's in the neighborhood.
I think Volkov is probably about six,
eight.
How tall is he?
I'm guessing six.
Eight is four inches shorter,
so,
so yeah,
I think struve is just seven feet,
so pretty close.
It's an interesting situation the heavyweight division has because you
essentially have Alistair Overeem who's really looks like the only credible
challenge other than Francis and Ghana.
Francis and gone on and he's like a big win over somebody and he would have
gotten it if he had beaten junior dos Santos.
That would have been as big.
Yeah,
it's big cut.
Frances would've gotten the possibility or the opportunity rather to get a big
win over real big name with junior,
but junior pissed hot.
So now Francis has to wait for another opponent,
but he's the most exciting challenge her.
But you still have Allister.
I think Derrick Lewis is coming back.
Who just beat Derrick Lewis.
So many beat Derek close.
Oh,
Mark Hunt kind of beat his ass.
Wasn't,
wasn't the best fight for Derek.
And then he quit.
He retired after is over and it changes.
Mind
point is there's only like legitimately like four or five real contenders that
are exciting in the whole heavyweight division,
which is just crazy.
Oh my God.
He poked him again.
October.
Stephan's true.
Just poked Volkov again.
God dammit.
They're too tall.
Too Tall to be fighting.
Mark Goddard going to straighten it out.
There's some,
there's some downsides being too tall.
Like you look like shit and close.
No snow shoes.
Like cool.
You know,
like there's just too big no scuba gear.
Everyone's rent shit.
Everything about that car.
You can get GD three not up in air.
You wouldn't fit.
Yeah.
Like that was the thing was shack.
He would buy cars and cut out the back seat.
Put socks,
man.
Cheyenne ass seat.
And there's only certain cars you can have.
You think they'll ever be a super heavyweight division?
Never.
There's not enough heavyweights.
It seems to me that they shouldn't have a weight class.
It's just like the heavyweight division in boxing.
Like when David Haye fought value of,
I think value of is 300 pounds.
Yeah.
So you're saying there's just two oh six and above to the limit to 25
yeah,
like two 25 I think there should be a two Oh five to 25 and then have added
fuckers.
Yeah,
to 25 on up.
I wonder why they don't do that.
But there's also you're gonna get some slop like usually,
typically,
especially with the golden stitch around these days,
if you're over to 80,
you getting sloppy up and then it's bad for the product.
The mound.
Okay.
Pit Pass him any test including him at this.
He's doing nothing.
Nothing.
My past immigration,
fuck be tough man.
I bet he could like some like um,
what are those stones called?
Well,
it's big fucking stones.
Atlas stones.
He would probably pass an atlas stone certification test.
That's about it.
It's just bad for the look.
The size of that dude picking up rocks and shit.
If he hears this and I run into him,
it's going to be trouble.
I think you'd be okay.
He's fun.
He's much calmer.
He did.
You saw that.
Did he,
how did he die and came with Thrones?
He gets stabbed with a spear and then they brought him back to life with
witchcraft
bro.
I didn't know right now they're trying to bring back life.
I don't know.
They found it and date it for God sakes.
Last time I saw him as he crushed that guys who was two years ago,
Bro.
But you know where I'm at.
My Dad.
I thought you already passed it.
Nah Man.
Well trust me,
it's worth watching.
I Bet I'm a fan.
I'm a fan.
I assume they were bringing them back though.
It stopped.
Avoid spoilers and shit.
These guys are rock 'em sock 'em robot in this bitch.
Struble it's more tired.
Good thing is that big cardio.
Cardio is just such a giant factor in fights.
Dude.
In heavyweight it every,
every division,
every really heavyweight.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Oh that's,
there you go.
That's it.
When skyscraper falls down,
there you go.
That's it.
What,
how many more times we see strew fight?
How many more times is going to get KOD?
How many times has it been caseload?
Start flatline.
Dim Travis Browne,
k Odom.
This dude,
just k Odom.
Roy Kale,
raw k owed him.
I feel like it looks worse cause he's so God damn tall.
You know what I'm saying?
Like have a burger king burns down.
We don't want you.
If a skyscraper burns down,
we watch it.
It's a good point.
You know what I'm saying?
That's a good point.
He CalEd Steepbank inside like kick then boom.
Yeah,
he knocked out Steve Bay.
It's also heavyweights like that's what you do.
You get like people get knocked out,
man.
Yup.
This is true.
Okay.
How many people watch us?
You think?
Boom.
That upper cut?
Yeah.
I was sober worldwide.
How many people watched us?
Nah Man,
you was this on fight pass.
Just fight path.
How many people are on fight pass
the subscriptions?
Is it around 200,000 I have no idea of that.
It's more than that.
I ain't saying,
I don't know.
So is the only way this is playing on five pounds for it,
right?
In Rotterdam
it's like on Fox sports on Schneider over there or something.
It's like that's a great mood.
Okay.
Bruce,
look at Bruce Buffer about Bruce looks exhausted a fire up here we go.
Go.
Okay
God.
Bruce goes everywhere he is.
Listen,
if you're,
if you want to keep that job like that's what you do.
You have to go everywhere.
Yeah.
They use that Joe Martinez though too,
because he speaks Spanish.
Yeah.
Blake's good if Bruce one.
Yeah,
he's really good.
I don't want Joe for over it.
But if Bruce and he was in WC,
but if Bruce wants to take a break,
he can like you don't have to fly to Rotterdam for one night.
You know,
it's one of the reasons why I didn't want to get his knee operated on because
they don't want to take some time off.
It's got a blown ACL.
Did you see the video in ball at ACL out?
It's classic sad.
He's doing like a fucking karaoke thing and fell at the uh,
in Las Vegas.
Man.
Who the fuck they took Francis off the car,
didn't they?
Yeah.
Breaking my heart.
Well the junior dos Santos things breaks my heart too because it was just a
diuretic.
Like I don't get it.
They found a trace amount of a diuretic in a system like that is not helping
him.
There's not going to help him fight.
You know what I mean?
It's just not the only thing that could be,
cause you could say that a diuretic might be used to mask steroids.
True.
I think they do do that.
Correct.
Right.
So there,
there's potentially he was mass something,
which I don't think so,
but also no one else wants to step up the plate and fight Francis [inaudible]
who wants to that guy's terrifying.
Fuck all that short notice.
You.
What else?
Elster over here.
It was like no elsewhere.
Like mm.
Good.
Alistair Overeem turned it down.
Alice,
just write about the fight for the title.
Who else is there?
Yup.
For doom verse Derrick Lewis.
Now Dick Lewis,
same p one.
Houston.
Shout out Derrick Lewis.
Yeah,
that a person saving people with his truck.
Um,
the people that got down truck.
Who else?
I mean a d when Derek fights for doom,
if for doom wins,
he's got a real good,
real good argument for him being the next in line.
But if he doesn't or if it's not a good fight or if anything goes sideways,
you got Allister.
That's it.
Who else is there?
Francis Francis hasn't have a big name or a big person yet.
If Francis beat junior dos Santos,
do you got a big name?
We're going through his like,
yeah,
but
I feel that heavy weight division so rough.
The potential Francis has is absolutely world champion potential a hundred
percent but it's just like,
do you make the fight right now?
Who else does he fight?
The jds was the Mark Hunt.
Frances Khan's find some Russian.
He's ranked 11 in Australia.
They didn't want to take him off that mark.
Mark Hunt.
Francis makes sense.
More con jds makes sense.
He'd give him a big name so we can start Jim.
Then he'd give him a title shot jds or he fought Mark Hunt.
Remember Jda deal kicked him back in the day.
But I don't know if Jay Dee has is the same anymore.
Definitely not.
Still tough character.
Yeah,
he beat Rothwell or mill that super looking for.
He looked good against Rothwell great.
And I think that's when a rock wall mighta Pete electric
like drink.
It's true.
And then,
okay cane.
Obviously we're missing cane.
But the reason why we're missing Cain is we're not completely convinced that
Keynes healthy.
No,
we have no idea when he's going up fight.
Yeah.
I mean,
who knows?
God Watch friends,
his first cane because canes fighting Steve Bay.
Next one,
he's healthy.
That's the fight they're going to make.
That's what they want to make.
Yeah,
but man,
I mean that when he's healthy,
those are three weird words.
Kill.
Those are kind of key.
Is he retiring?
Make some noise please.
I thought it sounded like Dan Horn.
I said,
I love you.
He said,
I'm sure we'll see improved.
Stefan's drew.
When he's ready to return to the octagon.
Look at my bow tie.
I just feel like at heavyweight,
so let's say k,
let's say cane,
we getting healthy so you have steep a cane next,
which was amazing.
Fight just went over for Breesa was awful.
Frances,
Alastair man or Mark Hunt.
So Mark Hahn's fighting that.
Uh,
is that,
is it more counselors Phi that Merson cat.
What do you think about DC versus DPA?
Love it.
I like dcs in that fight too.
He's got a real good chance.
DC was a murderer at heavyweight beat does show a Josh Barnett not losing any
weight.
Didn't cut a goddamn thing shorter than everybody.
Throw him around like frisbees or straight up.
God Damn those look after seven and both divisions,
it gets super suspect.
They see it says,
see,
it says champion Jon Jones.
It should just be a.dot.
Dot.
For now it should be needle needle needle.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Is that too much?
Just pith pills be like A.
Dot.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
We get the fights coming up.
So UFC fight,
not fight night rock called branch.
Okay.
Shogun st Prue to how dare you personally though.
That's on banking.
On baby.
Yeah.
That's a good fight.
But I like Rockhold branch to men.
I really do.
I liked that fight.
Nunez shift.
Gencos fun.
Yeah.
That's going to be fun.
Oh,
you're doing that one?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I am doing that one.
I was going to be in Edmonton as it is,
but now they have to world title fights on the card.
So then they have the bantamweight title and then they have mighty mouse to
mighty mouse ray board.
Yeah,
that's a weird one,
right?
Because mighty mouse wants to break the record and he,
uh,
he had an opportunity to break the record if he fought TJ.
And a lot of people like trimming the Tj fight down and I heard the African,
I'm good money.
And he still was like,
Nah,
Kimmy Ray Borg.
We said he wants Tj to fight someone at 125 pounds first.
And so you want to know that it can make the way in May and get away.
Even Tj,
you know,
he was like,
I can make do it as on track to make weight,
you know?
I don't know.
It sounds like an excuse from Dj.
I love Dj,
but also him fight and Ray Borg while he's really close to history.
I mean,
I get it.
I don't,
because you want to be a star.
You gotta fight Tj fight Dominic Cruz.
You got to fight Cody.
Garbrandt yeah,
you're just going to stay beat.
Like,
you know ray boards.
A monster has a great nickname,
tells Mexican devil for God sakes.
However,
Mrs [inaudible] but it does not.
It does nothing for Demetrius besides I guess breaking the record.
Right.
But he might not even make the weight.
Ray Boggs miss to wait a couple of times.
There's a lot going on.
How many times were Ray Borg missed weight?
See,
we could find that.
I want to say he's missed it twice.
It's a tricky weight class.
It's like when John Linacre was the,
the big thing,
everybody's thinking about him fighting for the title that he was just too big.
He just couldn't do it.
He just missed it.
Half the time.
Headline had Ray Borg,
sick of fans.
So what it said said sick fans are missing weight.
Hmm.
When we got here and just say,
let me know when you find it Jeremy.
But like ray board versus Dj does,
it does nothing.
No one cares.
Yeah.
It doesn't.
No one cares.
But it does get them to that magical number for personal reasons.
It's good powerful lizard on his shirt for personal reasons.
Good for DJ.
Why does he have a lizard or on a shirt?
Cause lizards are awesome.
This is super in Elizabeth.
I don't know man.
That's a good question.
Yeah.
I like fancy stuff.
I have not put a lizard on my city.
I want you to weigh this Putin lizard.
Maybe it stands for something.
It stands for love Dan.
Where the Lizard,
the Lizard from Hulu.
What would I do to explain it?
Doesn't damn want to fight.
Yeah,
they fucked him over man.
He's got like some issue with his heart that is totally non life threatening and
he's in fantastic shape where he was before he uh,
stepped away and they were saying that he has like an irregular heartbeat.
Like he has an extra heartbeat.
There's just,
when there's with that stuff,
you know,
it's tough man.
It's such a risk for the commissions,
the ground to fight.
Let's say his harp fucking exploded in the room.
Shit,
I don't know man.
I don't think anything.
I think he's fine but also fit.
What's he going to do?
What do you do Dan?
Like you're great.
You're great.
A competent.
He got this Gig.
We can do stop doing that and can come back and compete at one 70 you beaten
Woodley.
I think you come back at one five to 55 it doesn't even look very lean.
It doesn't look the same anymore.
True.
True knows.
Who knows?
I missed it twice.
Twice,
twice.
One.
Both of those fights.
Yeah.
See that ain't good though.
It's not good.
When you've got a guy with a lot of pressure on him headed towards the title,
do you start looking for excuses?
They start,
you know,
if you lost,
if you took on two separate occasions,
you haven't made the weight.
That's like the argument with Khabib.
Right.
We've been a lot of fight in between those two fights he did.
Who'd he lose to?
Justin Scoggins.
Scoggins is no fucking joke.
Tough customer.
Where's he at these days?
One 25 just it does nothing for me.
I'm a scientist.
I know it's mighty skew.
Pound for pound number one.
Yeah.
He's still your number one.
He is now for sure.
I'm,
Tom was my number one after a in DC.
But yeah,
I moved John Closer to the number one position.
Although I've seen,
I think there are debatable and changeable.
Um,
cause I think mighty mouse wins in these spectacular ways who,
but again,
so that's the big,
he's beaten and you know,
it's not like that's the toughest division at all.
Wow.
He lost it.
Pedro Munoz.
God Damn,
who is that Oh word.
Those are the two guys.
Hm.
Interesting.
Um,
but yeah,
one point,
the stocking,
the only argument with the mighty mouse is who is he beating?
You know,
the five.
So Hutto was seven to know.
God Sakes.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what man,
there's a lot of like soup,
protect and go guys and that division,
I just feel like there's no one mean.
So Hutto was really green in terms of MMA.
I mean he really had not been fighting MMA that long.
He's fantastic wrestler,
but it's MMA experience too much.
Where I'm pleased there's too much too soon.
Yeah.
But that's a division of [inaudible] seven,
you know,
seven know,
get the title shot.
There's a lot going on there.
I need to stop being a fatty.
Oh,
that's a good,
well that helps me feel comfortable.
You gotta Make Weight Ray Borg on missing way.
I need to stop being a fatty that sees like fat shaming himself.
I'm not behind that.
Um,
so it's,
it's the,
the Co main event them and then Nunez shift.
Chanko yeah.
How many papers have you buys some that do and he gets you tell me
Neil Magni dos Anjos Ooh,
that's actually interesting.
Hofeld Los Angeles back.
What do you think you can do at one 70?
You Look God damn good in his debut at one 70.
So it's talking about dos Anjos he looked,
he looked very good against Terex.
Half a dean.
It did look good.
He looks thick as fuck guy.
He's like shred in that picture and that's how he looks.
And he's fighting to pursue thought of.
And the picture pretty.
You thought of no comment.
Uh,
shading angles,
tanning shit.
It's Graham filters.
Those are filters,
Bro.
Dude,
I'll tell you the funniest fight on that card.
Jeremy Stephens,
uh,
Melendez.
Gilbert Melendez.
That's right.
Nobody even thought about that.
That's the flooding.
That's a phenomenal fight.
It's a good one.
That's a chaos fight.
Yes.
So wait a minute,
is El Nino going down to 45 or is Jeremy Stevens going up?
It's 45 it says it there.
It's 45 so Gilbert is cutting weight down to 45 has he ever done that before
too?
They still have fucking jds and Frances on this card.
I'd take that to here.
You take that down to that and be like,
what the fuck?
Where?
Um,
what,
what way does it,
does it say most positive?
It's 45 so he's cutting weight and he's going down to 45 that's crazy.
That's interesting.
Boy,
I don't know.
I just never done that before.
And he's like,
he's got to be like 35 36 no,
35 so he really is,
see it says one 55 there.
We'll find out.
We'll find out soon.
Anything more to add?
Brennan shop before we wrap this bitch up?
I don't think so man.
It's been a real spin real fast.
And then we got back together and did one of these.
Huh?
Even with a half a crew,
half the crew.
We have no conspiracies with Eddie.
Brian nut drop in some old school knowledge.
You're lucky because in Rotterdam,
I'm sure that some gems for you.
Yeah,
he probably explained the government to us.
He was explaining this whole government system and then Eddie,
I went,
man,
I feel a little flat today in any way.
Did you say flat?
Yeah.
And then just went off and he's full on these days.
Apparently they were debating whether or not these crazy North Korea is really
like what's happening in North Korea.
Like he doesn't believe any of it.
And uh,
they were debating like,
why you don't fall off the earth?
Is that what was going on?
If the earth is spinning so fast and we're going so fast through and on a turn,
how come we're not just flying off of it?
And when you say debating pain,
who,
uh,
other dudes that are there with them,
it's like one of those things where you could find out about gravity.
You just do a Google search and you know,
read some papers about how,
how mass works and you know,
how it works in space and what gravity is and what causes the force of gravity
and talk.
It's all,
they've done experiments for hundreds of years.
It's fake news.
Fake News.
I think he's enjoying himself.
I think half the fun.
We don't think he really believes it.
I think he does,
but half the reason why he believes his cause he's enjoying himself.
Like he's like,
he's,
he's spicing up life with these wacky conspiracies.
Like everything's Goddamn,
consider everything.
You never hear Eddie like look at something that's in the news and go,
wow,
it's probably,
we're just looking into it too much.
Everything like you and that Chester with Bennington to Lincoln Park Guy,
he's like,
you know about that,
right?
Like I don't,
I don't man,
I def definitely don't.
But the problem with Darwin is man,
like the guy's dead and if he killed himself and he's got kids and a family got
six kids,
Mr. Rowe get out six kids,
that's a hard one.
It's a hard pill to swallow.
Swallow.
Yeah.
But also I think you need people like getting this word.
I want,
I like that he's in the world.
Like I don't want everyone to agree with all the news.
Oh,
well I think it's fun to a certain point.
Well that's one of the reasons why Eddie says your Jujitsu genius,
cause he marches to the beat of his own drummer.
I mean he really does.
He has like ideas in his head and then he's just like,
we're gonna make this fucking work.
But when you say drum,
it's not like your standard drum.
It's like a star ship drum.
And there's that alien with seven arms banging the word.
We not sure if the eclipse is a real,
if NASA NASA hopes to sell sunglasses.
Ah,
see I enjoy Callen.
It drives them nuts.
But I'm like,
I want colorful people in the world.
Man.
Talon is almost as silly in the other direction.
Correct.
Never believes anything is a conspiracy.
Ever.
He thinks Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone and he'll tell you about,
actually you should read Vincent [inaudible] book like,
yeah,
I have.
It sucks.
You didn't read it.
And I feel like we're in the middle.
You and I usually like,
I'm like,
I could see that,
you know,
like I get it,
like I'll entertain it but to,
until we start talking about the earth is flat dom out any shit that doesn't
really involve me where I don't either have a stake in it or I don't actually
know what happened.
I don't have a dog in that fight both sides and I'll,
I'll swing back and forth in my own head.
Like I'm the,
I'm,
I don't convince myself my own self.
I like say something,
I'll go man.
And he'd probably wrong about that and then I'll start arguing against myself as
well.
What about this dude?
I was convinced at big foot was actually real for like 20 minutes,
just like you fucked idiot.
You been no long time ago.
I was watching the video of big foot,
like the famous video and I was like,
what if big foot is real and I'm just an asshole?
Like what did this whole time I would say it's fake.
It's fake,
it's not fake.
And that poor guy actually capture on film the poor die,
but see if you send me a little bit of bigfoot expert.
I'm not so close minded.
I'm just going to shut them down.
I'm listening to it and then be like maybe till you realize there are no big
foot experts.
Every big foot expert you meet is kind of a loon is full of shit or will have
them as super nice guys.
But when you get like deep them,
I had one dude on the podcast tell me he would cut his pinky off to find out if
Sasquatch is real.
He's a grown man.
I don't know.
Like I had a guy who wanted to follow the eclipse through all the states I drive
with.
He flew on a Suitland Dick before or after you put the sunglasses on him.
See that's why I said he's the guy,
he's the maintenance guy around my house and told him get the fuck out.
I can't have you around my kid.
A weird,
weird,
some weird people in or a definitely weird.
People are weird,
but it's fun.
All that stuff over and over and over again.
It looks easy.
Clips over and over and over.
We got these classes.
I could look at a picture of the eclipse and go,
I get it.
Yep.
Good.
I'm fucking good.
I'm good.
And then he's saying the next one's in like 24 years in Dallas.
Okay,
I'll be there.
See Ya.
I'll meet you there,
bro.
Talk to you then.
Okay.
He was like,
I'm going to buy a property down there and rent it out or when the eclipse Tom
up for the one fucking day.
It's a terrible business.
I super smart.
Plan for one day,
21 day now fucking clean up.
You make $100.
You gonna kill it,
Bro.
How much property you buy in my probably charge him double.
Like what do you do?
What?
They're just going to stand outside your house with glasses and they need to get
back in their car.
Go.
Yeah,
it was done.
That's it.
They don't need to stay the night for that and doesn't happen on a sun like is
it the summertime?
Summertime in Dallas.
It's like summertime on the sun.
Miserable.
It's like you might as well be living on the sun.
Summertime in Dallas,
like 185 degrees.
You go outside,
you personally the flames.
No one's going to stand on and say you're fucking stupid house with this weird
sunglasses.
The thing is who's crazier?
That guy who falls the clips and he's boring as fuck,
but at least the eclipse is real.
Or a guy like Eddie Bravo who believes in big foot flat earth conspiracy
theories.
Eddie's funnier.
Different.
No,
I'm not saying Eddie.
Eddie's funny.
However I'm saying who's crazier?
Yes.
Good,
good question.
What do you think is crazy?
I don't know.
It depends.
It's a case by case,
you know,
like do you believe in Ghost?
No.
I'm going to say it's right now.
What you chase big fun?
No.
You believe in ghosts,
Jamie?
I don't think so.
No.
Oh,
you're open to that.
See if I'm ready right now.
Go when you said you think so.
I'll go look into it.
One of the guys that had on my podcast is named Rupert Sheldrake and he has a
very compelling thought.
He thinks that everything has a memory.
That memory is not just a function of like your neurons and your brain's
yourselves.
Because here's the thing,
you have memories from the time when you were a child,
right?
From Tommy,
you were a little Kish.
Almost every cell in your body regenerates every seven years.
Where's those?
Where are those memories being stored?
Like where are they in the neurons?
Like where are your memories that you definitely have of your childhood or are
those memories not really your memories anymore?
Is it you remember having those memories?
So you have sort of like a rehashed version of it that you put or put in your
head and sort of almost like re telling yourself a story.
You know what I'm saying?
So you don't like,
there's a lot of shit that I know happened when I was in high school,
but quite honestly I don't really have a good memory of it.
But does that tell you the fact,
is that just a function of the human brain where it can't remember so much data
because we only use what seven would they say seven apps?
That's not true.
That's,
that's 7% of the brain is something that people repeat over and over again.
It was in that movie,
Lucy.
It's a myth,
is it?
Yes,
absolutely.
There's different parts of your brain that are responsible for different
functions,
frontal lobe,
all that.
There's not 7%.
We use your brain.
You use your whole brain,
the wider some people's brains.
So I don't mean why are some people's brains like,
you know,
they can remember to the t when they were a kid,
like all these memories and there's some people that is,
don't write anything about better memories.
For sure.
My memory's pretty good for facts.
Pretty good.
I'm just being,
I mean,
I remember,
uh,
don't,
don't get me wrong.
It's like,
Oh man,
maybe stop smoking weed.
You can remember high school,
I remember who massive amounts of data from high school.
Yeah.
What I'm saying is I don't have a real memory of it.
Like I can remember getting laid in high school.
Right.
I can remember when it happened.
If I could tell you events.
Yeah.
You remember,
you remember a scary events.
You remember happy events.
You remember sad events,
you remember big moments,
big explosions in your consciousness right here.
Brains you're designed to remember like negative things more so than positive
things.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
It just gives the Diet.
What are you gonna Remember?
Positive things all day and pat yourself on the back.
Awesome.
Hit in the head by a rock,
something to eat you.
I think,
um,
things,
what we think as a memory,
we'd like to think of a memory.
Like,
look,
I've got a memory of that fight.
I've got a memory of that combination that landed.
I got a memory of Stephan struve crumple it up.
I see it pretty clear right now.
Right.
But even right now it's sort of like a little shitty slideshow even right now.
Cause you see it clearly,
but you also don't care.
Exactly.
I'm to walk out of here and I won't remember anything about that really.
I know,
but it just happened.
I mean,
just how it is not important to me.
So I don't try,
I don't store it away.
Whereas certain stuff like my sat or my big appointment on Tuesday,
but you know,
I remember that stuff.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
Um,
I remember a lot of like,
I remember flashes of things,
and this is weird coming from me because I have a very good memory on paper.
If you think of the amount of things that I can recall during a podcast,
he amount of fights that I can recall a during broadcasts and in the middle of a
fight and all the different martial arts moves I have in my head and who used
them against who and where and what.
But that's,
that's a different thing.
Those are,
that's knowledge and statistics and numbers.
Numbers and memory.
And I and I have and our members certain clips of it.
But as far as like my own life,
like I did two sets last night,
killed,
don't remember any of it.
We too,
Hi Dad might've been a problem.
But here's the other,
here's the other thing.
What is this?
Highly Superior autobiographical memory,
the detailed recollection of events that occurred in the distant past,
but like Marilu Henner has,
oh yeah,
she's got it crazy.
She can,
she can tell you,
you could say February 22nd and she can go in February 22nd,
1978 you go,
that was the Tuesday.
It's like rain man.
Yeah,
it's brilliant.
Most people don't tell you that was president.
And you know what's weird is like there are certain things when people go,
remember we did this.
I'm like,
God,
not really.
But then something will trigger it like a smell or a song and then it comes and
people hold the Nile.
Find the file on the banker.
It is like you're in your closet digging around.
Like,
I don't want to look what I got a box.
Oh look at this.
Yeah.
If you see like some pictures like Whoa,
a smell,
a set,
someone to say something or a Moviola Cag.
Remember I was at,
yeah.
That's why it's really dangerous to convict people based on witness testimony.
If they see a crime,
people,
they don't really remember things.
Right.
And then I'm sure it,
you know,
the night before,
like God will remember this and God,
he is a man animal and they create this narrative that they wished they want to
see and they think it was real.
And it also a part of it is a real problem if,
uh,
it was traumatic,
but does this remembering a crime that you didn't commit?
There's people that can plant false memories and in their own head,
not in their own head.
And when they're trying to get false convictions and whatnot,
they can make fast and stuff they didn't do fuck.
Oh,
that makes sense.
Because the pressure of being interrogated is crazy for people.
A lot of people just making a murderer.
Oh boy.
Oh yeah.
Kids,
I think he got out Brendan,
he fucked the Brendan Name.
But Brendan Udacity,
there's a lot of people that are not convinced that making a murderer was
correct.
There's a lot of houses that convinced that it was biased.
It was biased in the way of making that guy look like he was innocent.
I heard the same thing is good for the documentary,
like he's innocent.
But we look into it.
He's a bad,
terrible person.
It could have very well have been guilty and they framed them.
That's possible too.
It's like the mark Furhman Oj thing.
Like people think that Mark Furhman planted those gloves on Oj,
but who doesn't think Oj was guilty?
But that,
that was one who thinks Oj is innocent?
Let me know.
Well,
I live in this little neighborhood so I do shout out to Lj Simpson,
but I'm sure that Mark Furman,
that was just for the defense to paint that or the prosecution.
Right.
Paint that narrative to maybe put that seed in everyone's head,
but everyone knows fucking Oj did it.
Yeah,
but he planted evidence,
you know like doing that,
doing that alone.
Sneaky Shit.
Yeah.
Most people think Oj did.
It does a few people that think like,
I heard the crazy ones like Oj son did or something like that.
I'm like,
what?
I'm still balls deep in the Oj stuff.
Anything he does,
I watch it.
But like I said,
my brother went,
God I,
I went,
God,
I wish I really knew the truth about o j and j.
My brother looks at me,
he goes,
are you shitting me?
Like we all know the truth man.
But people put all these different stories out there where you're like,
God,
maybe you didn't do it,
but I just want to know for a fact like that.
Like what?
How did it really go down?
Do you think he's ever going to come out and be like,
listen,
no,
I don't think he did.
I don't think he necessarily remembers anymore.
You think he was just in a frenzy?
I think it's entirely possible that he's a sociopath and a narcissist with brain
trauma,
brain trauma.
And I think that a lot of times narcissists and sociopaths like to that degree,
like he's just charming the world.
Hey,
I'm Oj Simpson.
I'm a good guy.
I've always been a good guy.
Basically the conflict free life,
Yo,
I just want to go be with my family.
Got a sounds like a man.
He's got a weird thing going on man.
Like he's trying to paint this image all day long of him being a good guy.
Meanwhile,
he's got these demons and knows dad was gay and they said that's why he beat
like a lot like you so upset about that.
See,
I don't trust that guy when he gave that,
uh,
you know,
he's like snapped at the judge.
Yeah.
A little part of that was super weird and you definitely shouldn't do that when
you're trying to get upset about something.
Corrected him on something.
He's like I said I wasn't there or something like that.
I forget what it,
what it was like the Las Vegas Room definitely didn't handle it well.
Who?
Look man,
when you're a man and you're locked up with other men,
you know,
as prisoners all day long forever.
It's just,
it's a horrific existence.
It's amazing that he was able to get through it at all and then still pull off
that kind of charm and not can only do so.
Yeah,
he was killing it in there.
Like he was the prime example of a,
of a prisoner and it was like he started organizing church groups and like
feeding everyone's lunches and like,
he was cool.
Wow.
Well you find meaning in that shit.
I wonder if you'd like,
has like a deep what's going on?
He's Chloe's dad.
Yeah.
Lot of people think he's closed.
Dad Get the fuck out of here.
What?
Chloe's not half black.
Uh,
well they just don't love black guys.
They is that what it is?
Hmm?
Some people do well and you know Oj was super close with strong rumor.
That shit strong rumor.
It's strong.
No one be surprised.
Uh,
I would,
well my point was like what kind of memory of the event?
Okay.
We both agree he did it right.
So if he did it,
what kind of memory does he have?
Do you remember sticking the knife in them?
I remember that traumatic event.
I wonder,
I wonder if you're a sociopath and I wonder if you've been telling people for
all these years that you're innocent.
I'm all you remap trying to find the real killer.
I'm trying to get out of it upon the real killer.
Everyone's all,
not once did he bring up the real killer.
I'm trying to find my wife's killer.
The reason why,
I mean,
he never said that during any of the parole thing when he can't get out.
Oh No,
not my wife's killer.
Yeah.
Never on this.
Someone killed my wife.
That's ship's sailed a lot of time.
Me,
I'm being tried for it.
I'm being unjustly accused.
He didn't say that case that I lost,
he came out with a book.
If I did it.
Yeah,
he was going to,
but he didn't release that book.
I thought he did.
Not all the proceeds went to the the gold.
No.
Um,
I believe,
I'm pretty sure that the publishing company backed out of that price.
Smart on their part.
Yeah.
You can't do that,
dude,
while you have them on the podcast.
Oh,
I don't know if he would do it,
but if he did do it,
yeah,
I have them on.
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
I'd have to Amman,
I did it
shit up.
IDF is right.
It's hidden right there.
Remember?
That's what they had to do.
Oh,
that's right.
If I did it in the eye and on Amazon by j Simpson.
Jesus Christ.
That's,
that's still,
I thought they pulled that confessions of the killer in all caps,
all that Goldman and Kim Goldman.
Nick,
that's how it happened.
They had to,
they're,
they're getting all money,
all the money,
but in did he really right,
the full story.
Yeah.
Where did the rights to them because double jeopardy,
right?
Can't be make money off the crime is sorta what it is.
How much money do and also they have a civil case against him.
How much money you think he made off that book to God.
You don't make that much money off books unless you're just fucking,
you do feel like Bill O'reilly,
k Rollins or some shit if you're writing books are like old people read by a lot
of books.
If I did it,
but we kind of know how you'd do it.
If he did it.
Is it really need to read the kitchen knife or stab both of them go to Chicago,
called the lawyers,
come back,
act dumb.
Kadash and helps me out.
Rinse,
repeat.
Does it say how many books?
So many books they sold?
I'm looking down.
I got to think it was not much.
I don't even know it was out and I'm all about this.
He got some sort of crazy settlement.
Right?
It was like $35 million settlement or something like that.
33 million.
But how much has he been paid?
I used to know is um,
um,
Ron Goldman sister.
Really?
Yeah.
How'd you know her?
She worked,
um,
on something that I did for,
she was very nice.
Very cool check.
Brian ran into the dad in Phoenix selling men's shirts.
What's the big paws?
Men's,
I was trying to think what is selling,
but I remember sound like men's golf shirts or some shit.
Like the struggle is real for Ron Goldman,
you know,
like game over,
you lose a child and it goes down like that.
Just,
just hard believe that that guy is now going to get out.
What do you do?
I mean you only got certain amount of time left on this planet.
I,
I probably got a hand.
I'd probably,
yeah,
Hammer beat.
It's going to be tough to get Oj still pretty athletic and black,
so I would,
I probably get a gun and when he gets out,
drive down to Florida or if he comes back to Brentwood,
it's going to make it super easy on you and probably shoot them.
Could be headed to reality TV.
And when I called,
Oh my God,
watching that documentary about them because I completely forgot about all the
weird stuff he was doing before he did go to jail and show in Vegas where he
had,
I didn't even know about it.
Seeing it on the documentary shows everything I had to do.
Wrap.
Yeah.
You had a rap song that after he murdered his wife before he went to jail and
like 2005 or six soon.
I'm innocent.
I'm innocent here too.
Good.
We're going to get pulled off of youtube for the Oj Simpson.
Oh my God.
Wait a minute.
We got to play this.
Let's,
let's ride.
Let's ride this.
Give us some volume.
Oh my God.
Who are these girls?
White face
depth titties out.
God,
this is a real,
this is a real music video.
America's most wanted.
This is crazy.
He's dressed like Elvis.
I can't believe this is real.
Oh
look,
those Teddy's gimme some volume here.
People hear this,
right?
People on Youtube are Hannah's.
No.
Oh,
that'll get taken down.
Problem not for you.
Play just the audio way.
Oj Simpson get juiced.
What year did this happen?
Like 2004 2005
this is insane.
This is insane.
It's all these girls taking their pants off.
See,
he was doing a prank show and you got juice was the tag line.
Oh my God.
He did it.
He did a fucking prank show after he murdered two people.
He's got a midget on his lap.
This is insane.
I can't believe it.
I've seen this.
Oh my God.
All you play or haters.
Get on your knees and get some of these grabbed his crotch.
He said these nuts.
This is crazy.
And you got to think,
is this 2005 is that what you said?
So he's got to be like 60 years old when this is happening.
Damn.
It only has 15,000 views.
Well,
check in and a couple of days.
We just helped the juicy stuff.
Think people knew about it,
but another reason he needs to come on the God damn podcast.
Yeah.
Maybe it will come on dressed like Elvis again.
No,
no.
Maybe it come on justice white face.
God Damn.
This is nuts.
He's a terrible,
yeah.
I wonder if he was like,
look,
I rarely,
I make money and so on through this idea at him.
Look at him with a do rag him.
Yeah.
Don't piss them off though.
Very strange.
You did a Bingo at like a white face with like a secure I old people home or
something.
Oh my gosh.
Struggle is real.
This is so strange.
I can't believe this.
This rap song where it's like it's hard in the streets in La.
That is true.
Yeah.
He was like a legit rap song though.
This is the remix Jamie.
It's got a good point.
Both of them are good.
We don't need to watch anything on a terrible person.
I wonder what he's,
I mean I feel like a guy like that probably like would do anything.
It's like just get,
we've got to figure out some way to do and who's going to be working with them?
You're not going to get like the top minds of Hollywood flock?
No,
no one's,
I mean he might pop up on some reality show,
but dude,
a matching knows hoes.
They were saying he was getting more women than ever when he got out,
when he was out of trial,
they said we went to Florida was just Dick and girls down.
Now you're killing it.
What ties got out?
What type of psycho chicks are hooking up with Oj right now?
Skanks there's people that are attracted to murderous.
It's like,
oh,
it's a normal thing like serial killers.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Girls like send pictures and there's something that some women like Charles
Manson tried to get married and that,
I guess the court was like,
Nah man or he maybe didn't get mad.
He said it's offered the things off,
but Charles Manson is ignite crazy bitch.
Yeah.
Madison's like,
look,
look at that.
Crazy hot and hot pad look at is high and tight fade though.
I liked that too.
I'm still mad.
A swastika tattooed on his forehead.
That's never gonna go away.
Come on and get that laser drop,
Bro.
No flood did even more pussy.
Dude.
Every time he's up for parole,
you ever see him go nuts?
Like he just fucked himself.
He goes opposite of
fucking hate your garbage,
man.
You made me.
People may mean your system,
your system.
Nice.
Dunkin looks so much like he doesn't.
That's Grayson Trussell.
You're racist.
You're fucking Jesus Christ.
So racist.
He's never getting out.
Imagine that crazy Trump.
We tried man.
That girl socks,
a Hella deck.
The meanest thicken the world gobble,
gobble gums.
She's probably just got moves that you never even heard of before.
I mean Charles Manson scene at all.
Yeah.
And he's conjugals does he get to Oh,
shaved their head.
Yup.
She shaved her head.
Damn.
I bet she's healthy.
That's a bad move,
honey.
These are eyes would get your wig until that shit grows back.
Some girls can't pull off the no shirt.
Shaved head test.
Oh my God.
Cause some girls looked pretty until you shaved their head and take their shirt
off and you go,
hey,
hey.
Yeah,
what did,
what did we do here?
What happened?
What was it?
Who are those people with them?
Said he was being too timed.
Oh,
she was fucking that other 26 Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
With,
with the,
the wolf guy,
65 six with his disciple,
Gray Wolf.
65 just months after her marriage license to wed the murderer expired,
bro.
She was getting dicked down by two old dudes.
Manson's 80 what does he expect?
Well,
she's getting Dick Downward.
Look,
this girl's obviously fucking bananas,
right?
What does she look like?
And he looked like get them all together in that picture.
Let me see that.
Pretty sure.
Damn.
And that the gray wolf guy got arrested for smuggling a cell phone at that guy.
He's like sneaky,
sneaky.
Some guys like sneaky bossy.
They'd like to be friends with a guy and bangs girl.
Those two old dudes are busting loads in this crazy
ah,
his loads.
All of them have like a swastika on just full of hate.
Just hate loads.
Hatless plus a squad car to cartoon.
Swasti got its forehead like wiggling what?
Playing for this dead loads.
They come in with like,
you know,
cartoons and people again,
they have an x for eyes.
It's just totally dead.
I'd just like a hit,
you know he kitchen fish and they're dead and their eyes cloud over and this
sperms looked like zombies for swastika on the forehand
80.
He uh,
he called the marriage off after apparent.
Maybe he found out that she was going to,
they're trying to get them to sign a document to give his body to them and they
were going to put his body in a glass crypt when he died and probably sell
tickets to some sort of weird.
He's good move.
You can do that to me,
man.
The fucking government had me in a casket forever.
She
wait.
So that was too much for Charles Manson.
Great.
You know what?
You're crazy bitch.
I'm out.
Take a certain amount of crazy.
If you want to bang a hot 25 year old and you're an eight year old serial
killer.
If Charles Manson goes,
you're crazy.
What the fuck?
How do they not arrest her on this cross?
He may at 27 year olds sought to wed the mastermind or the helter skelter murder
so that she could gain possession of his remains when he died.
That is beautiful.
Suck that old.
Oh Dude.
She had a sock that,
but you won't put his body in the class case you've were saying that is,
if that wasn't like,
like that was her plan all along.
It could have been like her along the way.
She's fucking nuts.
She wants a bank.
Charles man,
she's got some other nutty ideas to spread his great payments.
It might not have been some grand conspiracy that she masterminded from the
beginning.
I know how to get rich.
This is what I'm going to do.
Maybe it was like,
I'm fucking crazy.
I want to Bang Charles Manson.
What else I want to do?
I don't want to put his body on a fucking jar and let everybody look at it and
get them.
People pay a dollar to chuck it out.
Fill them up with formaldehyde.
Let everybody stare.
She's fucking nuts,
but she's got a lot of crazy ideas.
Go talk to her.
She'd probably tell you some shit about psychics and aliens,
but that one really sticks out.
Especially you're Charles Manson.
Not Good.
A lot of issues.
There is a lot of issues and you should have her on the puck.
No,
I should know where the podcast studio is.
You don't want that bitch finding out what she wants.
Your body and it's coming out just coming out trying to suck your Dick when he
get in your car with helter skelter discount down
the helter skelter and shit.
I love the stance he's got there though.
Look at,
scroll up to the power stance with the towel behind his neck.
It's got a tower.
Calisthenics.
That's how I keep my tan.
Nothing but hate.
Suntanning.
How'd he get Tan?
I just stares at the sun.
They let them get out,
I guess.
I mean what?
Uh Oh,
not entitled to a conjugal visit.
Oh.
So they never leave him alone with her.
Do you throw a blanket over it?
Have her give you a handy,
no,
you can't.
Oh God ain't having that crazy ass.
What does it say there in Bristow feely?
I was trying to see if that's what,
uh,
is the term for women who like psychopath killer.
Oh,
not even close.
Yeah.
She's not even close.
There's a lot of them.
I know that a Richard Ramirez,
the night stalker,
he,
uh,
he had a bunch of chicks that are trying to marry ahead.
Bundy was like,
he killed him.
The Gail on the gain of 10 times.
There's like Tinder for serial killers.
He's getting swipe less all fucking night.
Pull that phone out of his ass and just swiping because he comes in.
No,
that was dom or the hall to Ted Bundy though was a dime piece.
That was the problem.
Somebody who was like a famous singer got in his car and realized it.
Like as she was about to get in the car,
she realized that the inside of the door did not have any handles on it and she
freaked out.
Debbie Harry from blondie almost got in his car.
Like he almost got her tight moved.
Debbie Harry,
Ted Bundy lured her into a car.
Wow.
She almost fell victims.
He was the one thing they'll have incomes that charming.
Yeah.
Well it was Manson isn't,
but a lot of,
well he probably was though.
You know,
he's like charming and sort of an apocalyptic way where he understands like,
you know what,
what people want to hear.
They want,
they want some wise old mentor.
You know,
he's charming for bat shit crazy.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of those batshit crazy girls out there that want,
they want you to tell them about the Illuminati.
You know what a dad,
yeah,
there's,
there's a plan.
All these,
they're starting a race war.
You know,
there's,
there's people that want to hear like really nutty shit from some old daddy.
Dude.
God weird.
It's awesome.
It's awesome that people like that exist.
It's awesome that there's a girl who it's like her main goal in life is to fuck
Charles Manson fish tank.
Put them in a fixed then come on man.
It makes the world a better place.
No,
I liked it until they started killing people.
But when they're not a fan of that,
I would like you to not do that.
But I'm a fan of you wanting to marry Charles myth and live in a fish tank,
loving money off of it.
I love that you shaved your head.
You crazy too.
She and I love that you get tagged him from his old friend.
She's probably got some really stupid quotes tattooed on her ribs.
I'll just some hateful quotes,
probably like some demonic con ship,
something from some ancient book and translated from Latin to English,
some horrible shit and some horrible shit about the end of times.
Fuck say ah.
Ah.
I love it.
I love,
I love all the crazy in the world,
man.
I don't like the violent crazy.
I don't like when people,
you know what I,
my faith in humanity is somewhat restored because of Houston cause all the
videos that I saw all these people rescuing people in Houston,
I felt super good about that and man,
that made me feel really good.
Yeah.
Did you see that?
They were saying there's like no looting or anything going on.
Like some companies coming around and helping each other.
It'd be easy to lose Texas motherfucker.
They got,
they got a whole lot of guns.
That is a wrong place to lose,
but everyone has guns.
Even the criminals,
you know what I'm saying?
So you could get away with some shit,
but they're saying everyone's just gathered around helping each other out,
which is cool.
That's good.
You know,
I think Texas has a good sort of,
uh,
pride in taxes and they're being Texans is important to them.
It's,
it's very different than any other state.
California is very different than any other state too.
I mean,
it's got its own.
Every state sorta has its own vibe.
New York obviously has its own vibe,
but man,
Texas has its own vibe to the point where it's almost another country.
I agree.
Like Texas,
like if you meet someone from texts,
they want you to know you're from Texas.
Florida is not like that.
No.
You don't see people from Miami Super prideful or fucking Fort Lauderdale.
No,
no.
It's different.
But New York,
they are Boston.
They are deep.
They all of them don't have it.
Like Texas does.
Texas,
everything is Lone Star,
Lone Star Barbecue.
Lonestar,
this Texas,
that Texas truck,
unless plate say Texas truck.
Yeah.
And the different,
it's different.
It's Texas football.
They were,
they were a republic forever.
Like they're barely a state.
Like they were like one of the only states that like had this argument that they
could leave the country.
They could,
they leave the union point.
And it's also weird state that they have these giant ass ranches like Texas has.
He's like 80,000 hundred thousand like gigantic acre ranches to cool.
Well the,
it's weird.
It's like they're all rent.
They have so many ranches.
Also that bit from my,
uh,
act.
Totally true.
There's more tigers in Texas and private collections then all of the wild in the
world.
No frills.
Yeah.
That was the,
you ever see that bit that I used to do?
No.
Oh my God.
King's ranch,
911,215 acres.
Jesus Briscoe ranches,
560,000 acres,
Waggoner ranch,
530,000 acres this year.
Huge ranches.
911,000 acres is fucking banana owns king ranch.
Some dude who just balling calls himself a king of King [inaudible] death.
That guy might as well have his own country.
He basically has like a small European country.
Timmy can stay there right now.
I bet that she has like the size of Rhode Island,
Bro.
First of all,
there's a king ranch for truck.
They have their own trucks.
Oh,
that's right.
They do.
Bolon bolon controlled ranch.
King ranch.
Ford King Ranch.
F One under the Hood America.
Fuck America.
Just a big old eagle.
Dick got back up there to the what?
What's,
what's the heavy bag?
Hold on.
Why does it have heavy bags?
The fuck is all that.
Check out the new innovations.
Go Click on the heavy bag.
Why does it have all the weights and shit?
What does that the fuck is going on?
I totally high strength military can do.
This is Denis Leary's voice.
Um,
go back to uh,
the uh,
kings ranch page again too.
I guess it's a hunting ranch too.
Yeah.
Click on the lower left or the left hand side.
They have mini golf that they probably have zebras.
Oh,
okay.
See those deer looking at those deer's antlers.
He,
that Shit,
you know,
that comes from,
can you go back?
No,
no,
no.
That's all selective breeding.
They take these farm deers,
so super 12 hold on.
12,000 Neil Guy.
That's crazy.
That's her African animals.
If 12,000 African antelope,
it's a big ass antelope too.
Um,
Pedis.
Turkey.
Yeah.
770,000 issues.
The fuck the Turkey premiere destination for Texas whitetail.
Those deer,
a lot of them would they do is they get them from a,
when you see crazy antlers with all sorts of goofy shit all over him,
not like normal antlers.
A lot of that is like selectively treat a lot,
but it's real.
But their pet deer,
they grow them in these high fence operations.
They feed them this insane concentration that has like a old leg,
like heavy duty do protein in it lacked PDDs.
Yeah.
And then they bring in certain bucks that have crazy genetic characteristics and
they breed them together like x men at any hunter that sees like crazy deer with
all sorts of bullshit all over the place.
They go,
oh,
okay,
you're shooting a farm dear.
Oh,
they don't want to fuck with it.
No,
because a lot of those times,
these animals,
they're getting shot and he's like tiny little farms.
They talking about like a,
you know,
a few acres and nothing has no idea,
has no idea.
Basically like exact kidding Kalb.
And most of these people shooting him with a gun too.
So they just like setting up shop waiting for that thing to walk in the right
thing and boom,
they blow it away.
It's more of a execution than isn't lot fucked up.
What else they get on that ranch?
I saw a crocodile,
Nah,
that have crocodiles like yeah,
come on.
They get out of crocodiles.
They have alligators,
saltwater CROC.
He had some shit with tin grads hunting.
Coolest place on earth.
I can't believe they have their own fucking truck.
Here's the ranch wildlife.
Click on that.
They're looking at that.
Look at that.
That's a crocodile.
That big crocodile I come from.
Is that an algorithm?
I think it's an alligator.
I don't think they have crocodiles and um,
they have North American crocodiles in Florida.
But I don't think they have them in Texas.
The king ranch,
so they can do whatever the fuck they want.
A King ranch,
saltwater fisherman would be the best place in Texas coast.
TROUSSEU speckled trout and red fish.
Red Fish are delicious.
What else?
They got Turkey.
Answer their calls.
Do Money got wrecked by the storm.
By the way,
they might not even be here anymore.
Oh fuck.
King ranch and are they in Houston?
There's somewhere on the water.
If they have a,
if they have ocean fishing,
they will.
They just built their own ocean and then they might have just dug a fucking,
when we're going to get us a compound going about 17 feet deep with the
concrete.
What we designed this motherfucker to be aerodynamics when then 400 mile an hour
winds coming.
Just glide.
Yeah,
they got hit with that or why don't you Google king ranch?
Hurricane damage.
Let's see if they're still around.
Dude,
we don't get an invitation from the king ranch.
Come on down.
Shoot some halls.
I balls.
Hey King ranch on my end,
but you,
we should have hog out of a helicopter with me.
Hotter percent.
It's 100% I would deal with Ted Nugent,
but Doug,
Stan hope will get mad at me.
Tim Kennedy wants us to deal with it now I'm in right now.
Nigga talking about American Dad.
I'll shit some to hog with.
And Tim Kennedy in a fucking helicopter.
Kiki,
Kiki.
And by the way,
they donate all that food and the wild hogs are fucking delicious too.
And they really do have to shoot them and the fucking thing,
there's so many of them.
Yeah,
that's the way Tim explained it to her to Oh fuck.
Uh,
through doing king.
So does it say anything about the damage?
I'm trying to find something that has specifically king ranch in it,
but it hit right near the beach.
Okay.
It's stated disaster.
Yeah,
he must,
they wants to got fun.
Might have some special protection program.
They're so fucking rich.
We're just,
these walls go up.
We set it up.
So you just press a button here in the whole building slides or underground,
right quick bio dome complete where the x men that their fucking jet comes out.
It's like a big circle.
It opens up back to this king ranch baby may being mad king ranch.
Do you think that's like a place where you could,
I think that's one of the few places that I could live outside of California
that it would be like super happy.
Texas,
Austin,
Texas.
Anyway,
like Texas,
Dallas,
although it gets hot,
but I could definitely have been Austin.
Do you do shows there?
Uh,
did a show in Houston and Dallas.
Never.
I haven't been Austin yet.
Oh you got to do cap city comedy club.
I know.
It's the shit and I need to do.
It's amazing.
You'd love it.
I Love Austin.
The next level people to Austin's next level.
Crepe food too.
Fucking phenomenal.
But if you don't want a lobby takes you all over at the best Thai food in my
life in Austin.
Strong words.
I know,
right?
The best ever ever asked the Aubrey about it.
Just some good shit right over here on Ventura.
Really Love Thai food.
It's weird not wearing ties made it all the way.
I mean like I guess they're everywhere,
but like you go to like a lot of these Thai restaurants,
it's very rare that they're not ties working there.
If they have a white person has turned around and walked out.
Yeah.
Mexican,
Thai food.
I can't do I go to Sushi.
Has to white dude.
Fucking see you.
Yeah.
White dudes.
There's a lot of like white people getting into the Mexican food game and you
know you're gay.
I'm not mad at you and you can make some good Mexican food,
but better hide in the kitchen.
Keep up the solution and put the next one in front of me.
Come out with a big fake mustache.
She,
Hey,
hey Ho,
hey.
I want that shit to the police to have a lot of Mexicans working at it.
At least in Columbus.
When I was going there,
I switched and they were like,
well,
Mcdonald's bottom.
They fucked up and then they bought it back.
Right?
Yeah.
How good is your pull everyone,
even though people are getting sick.
Oh,
I heard it's delicious.
I haven't tried it.
Listen,
man,
cave me.
I get two orders of Guacamole and I'll get one of them.
Rice bowls,
please shake,
preach and I,
I'm eating fairly kido without eating all the rice.
If I just eat mostly the meat and the whackamole,
which is fantastic.
Quito there.
You get the heat of veggies for the bed and then you double me.
You do all the salsas.
Double Guacamole.
Delicious.
I feel good about it.
May two minutes.
Not Bad man.
For fast food,
it's about as good as you're going to get.
I agree.
Yeah.
Thai food,
they say to a certain point can be healthy too.
If it's like real tile,
like the needles and stuff.
Obviously not Kido,
but,
no,
not Quito,
but rice noodles,
man.
I'm I,
I'm struggling with Kido.
I'd drift in and out.
I mean,
pasta is just so strong.
I go back to it though.
You know the thing that knocks me back on course though is those are ketones,
man.
He Tajness ketones taking that key genic stuff.
That's the big one because it's so easy for me.
I take it when I work out in the morning,
I know I'll get before they do anything.
But you know,
you had homeboy like doctor keyed on your show.
He was saying,
really it's going to take about it.
Well how long is it a year?
18 months.
Some shit stinky.
Totally,
completely adapted and motherfucker,
it was discharging off the charts crazy though.
I mean with with ketones.
Crazy,
crazy,
smart,
crazy.
A lot of people disagreed with him.
I'd like to get those people on with them.
He was so small as to go performance.
Oh yeah.
And he was like,
he would like to stay in Quito and if you're trying to get on Ketone,
you listen to that podcast.
I'm a fuck are so discouraging.
He's like,
you need about 1218 months before anything happens.
And I was like,
uh,
you lose weight fast.
You date.
You know what?
The thing that gets me the most that I found was when my body became fat
adaptive,
right.
A switched over.
The thing that I could tell for sure was that my appetite was not crazy.
In the middle of the afternoon,
I don't have the ups and downs.
No ups and downs.
I went off and I'm doing pests.
10 I'm more carbs and I'm fucking starving.
Now.
Why pescatarian wife?
Just trying to just try it and mixing it up.
Like does it feel all right?
Just all right.
All right.
It gets a little challenging.
Like I ate so much salmon and tuna.
You gotta be careful with mercury levels and stuff too.
I know what the tune is.
Salmon not so much,
but you Leo,
Sardines,
oysters,
scallops.
It gets a little challenging.
A lot of salads.
How long have you been doing it now?
Two weeks.
Three weeks.
You're trying to get leaner like you just trying to try it out.
Uh,
just trying to get leaner and just mix it up.
Cause I know Quito works.
But again,
after listening to homeboy on the podcast like,
shit,
let's not like all the way in for 18 months.
Yeah.
Well I think he's talking about all the benefits.
You know he's talking about like this real serious metabolic benefits to be
gained from staying with it for long periods of time,
but I think that's probably the case.
But food is something else too.
There's a lot of pleasure with food.
You know,
like there's certain,
there's something to be said about enjoying life and I think you should eat
hell.
I follow what I call
the 80 20 principle or 80% of the time I eat really good preach and then 20% of
time I'll fuck off B two Monday through Friday.
I'm good man.
Then Sunday if I'm with my fam,
like we went to universal on Thursday at a bunch of chicken tenders.
I also work out like a fucking demon.
So everyday fat every day.
Stay fat.
Yeah.
But I thought just like a lasagna every now and then
the cheese and the meat and the,
Oh,
you don't have feeling when you take a big bite of fucking heavy sauce,
cheese,
Lasagna and you're like,
oh my mouth as well.
You know what fucks me up?
What gets me?
We were just talking shit about advertisements on dominoes went the last to
Metta hot dominoes pizza.
Domino's pizza they always have in the back.
If they can get it at a UFC,
actually they just get any kind of pizza.
But I've had Domino's before too.
It's not bad,
but this is the thing.
Here's the fat kid tip.
If you want to make sure you have a fresh pizza when you're ordering online
makes you ask for extra robust tomato sauce.
Cause they even,
I can't even an old one like God fuck this asshole that's for fresh sauce.
So they've put extra on it.
So it's a fresh pizza,
extra robust tomato sauce game over that pizza,
that fucking pizza man.
Dude,
there's a place in woodland hills to Nino's they shit in the mouth of dominoes
that you want your fucking American now's mouth.
You know the crocodiles and the crocodiles are biting cartoon characters.
No hope.
That's what they do.
Like splash,
rounded.
Just shit in the mouth.
We get a pizza.
Is it think crosser and crosser?
Think you're fucking writers are so good.
Oh I love the Domino's guy.
Wait noise.
Yeah.
He's not around anymore.
He's too fucking crazy.
The noise.
It looks like Charles Manson's girl with a job.
Why was he around?
What was the deal with the north?
They're trying to private market.
The kids back in the 80s and they brought out a game.
I had a stuffed annoyed when I was a seven up character to member.
Like spot.
Yes.
Doh and sugar.
I mean that's what it dough and sugar and cheese.
Don't give a fuck lot.
It is so delicious.
A fresh down those pizza.
Oh dear.
You know what's,
what's your favorite pizza combination?
I go again.
The extra robust tomato sauce,
cheese,
pepperoni,
Jalapenos,
tomatoes,
I think.
Oh and mushrooms.
I have three favorite college here.
My mouth is watering so bad.
Where do you get it from though?
Different pizza.
Pizza place just in general knows is really good.
Just in general.
Uh,
the classic for me is Pepperoni's with mushrooms.
I like it.
Get pepperoni,
mushroom to grow,
good pepperoni and mushrooms.
Some pizza.
I like a fucking flat cheese pizza.
Nothing.
He'll cheat God damn America and a nice cheese pizza,
but I can't have a dog.
I need some salts.
I get some sauce.
Here's where I deviate.
Double Pineapple,
double anchovy.
Oh,
you lost in the anchovy by
fucks with the pineapple.
Pineapple and anchovy pizza is fucking sweet and salt.
Sweet and salty with the cheese.
The sauce is oozing.
Oh Dude.
Double I.
I'd have to get them to like read it back to me.
They're like,
you sure you want,
are you trying to shit your pants to say double pineapple?
Double anchovy.
I'm like,
motherfucker.
I said exactly what I said,
avalanche or we don't want four diet cokes.
Yes,
it's so unhealthy but so robbed.
Damn good.
But if you're watching a movie or something like that,
like guardians of the galaxy two or something like that,
you get a double pineapple or you're looking at that,
that motherfucker right there.
That's deep dish.
Then that's a your deep dish.
Yeah.
It's more of a casserole.
I don't think that's deep dish.
It looks deep from my angle.
Double Pineapple.
Double anchovy.
Yeah.
That's a casserole.
Fuck.
That knows I like a nice Margarita pizza to Margarita Pizza,
dude.
I had pizza in Italy.
First of all,
fill level.
They'll,
the bread is different.
They have heirloom wheat,
they're wheat is older wheat.
It's wheat,
like are we used to be before we started fucking with it to make it more durable
to make it survive pesticides to make it last longer and to give more yield.
Like if you have an acre of land and you grow this heirloom wheat,
you will have a,
uh,
smaller yield.
Then you have an acre of our new better quality.
Yeah.
It's sort of like the same thing.
Like can you see tomatoes in the store and they're big and they're fucking Pale
as shit and they can throw a pleasant to pay the bounce.
Yeah,
they bounce.
Whereas you get an heirloom tomato,
they're only good for like a couple of days and then they start to rot.
But when you catch them in their fresh God,
they're like a fruit.
They're delicious,
they're fantastic.
So it was the best pizza ever.
Phenomenal.
Phenomenal Pizza.
Phenomenal Pasta.
And you can buy the pasta.
So the thing is like their pasta is available in the United States.
You've got to order it from like amazon.com but I think it's called double o
pasta or double o wheat.
Double or double zero and it's,
yes,
it's from Italy and you bought it tastes different while you're eating it.
It goes down easier.
Make Tortellini.
Yeah,
they make everything out of my mouth.
Is full flood is maybe somebody here.
Oh it could be.
Well a lot of people use zero in terms of,
I mean cine Alfredo,
I don't,
I don't fuck with that stuff.
I like,
I like red sauce and I'm not a white sauce guy.
I think it's like white people food.
It's like mayonnaise double zero double zero pasta typically milled in Italy
where a Miller's grade their flour using a zero rating,
a single zero flowers,
quite coarse in texture like a Powderly seminoma whereas triple zero is much
finer like cornstarch,
but everyday flower is usually classified as double zero.
Double Zero Spaghetti is the shit to,
it was so good man that but just this one company that had bought it for it got
damaged.
You make it at home.
Yes.
Your wife makes it.
I make
it to a cook.
I know how to cook,
Bro.
I can boil water board.
But then what kind of red sauce are you using?
Um,
I use uncle Steve's,
uh,
up on him.
I don't know the agent zero or uncle Steve's.
She,
yeah.
Uh,
hold on a second.
I'll find out right now.
But a mouth is watering like a motherfucking Arthur.
Hmm.
I tell you what,
everyone says New York Pizza.
Chicago pizza,
La Pizza Juice Sta.
Or you get a Gelina takeaway pizza.
Some of the best in the world.
Abot Kenny Pizza.
Abbott Pizza.
I've been looking for good pizza.
Looking for good pizza.
I'm in the middle.
Not,
I'm not on the west side,
so bro,
well,
I don't know around here,
but Hollywood area.
I don't know pizza down there that Joey Diaz does.
He's telling me someplace,
but uh,
I'm telling you man,
juice does.
Pizza came chip this Margarita Pizza.
Knock your Dick in the dope.
Really?
Yes.
Where's that?
That's a write off gold's gym there in Venice.
Right,
right,
right off rose Kinda.
It's like a,
it's like almost like a deli atmosphere.
Shit is delicious.
Damn Dude,
I know my pizza.
I just,
you just made me so hungry,
man.
My friend Steve [inaudible],
he's been on the podcast before.
He's the one that owns uncle Steve's.
It's all organic.
Um,
him and his wife created it and make it themselves.
It's best pasta sauce I've ever had,
but they have a,
a spicy pasta like Aria Bhakta who I like it spicy.
You got,
you gotta be careful with.
They're spicy.
They are not fun.
It's like real talents by,
it's got a kick to it.
Like Woo.
I think if you like it,
spicy sauce.
I love it.
Me Too.
It's got a kick butt.
It's all organic.
Super healthy and really good.
Delicious.
How hard is it?
Ticket?
I was exhausted and get,
or is it easy?
No,
he brought me in a gang of it.
He gave me like two cases of it,
but I think you buy it online.
You're just making your own pizza at home.
Fucking nightmare.
The content.
No fucking nightmare.
It tastes like shit too.
I was like,
when I see people get a pizza oven in their backyard,
I'm like,
that's something you're going to use three times complete waste of time ever
complete waste of time when you see someone doesn't work out.
Well,
I figured if I buy this treadmill,
no,
bitch,
you're not.
I can use that.
It's not the equipment.
It's your attitude.
It's a baker,
bro.
No,
you're not pizza man.
Chef Boyardee Anya,
let's wrap this up.
Let's,
can we get some fucking pizza and pizza?
All right.
See You folks.
Bye.
Pizza,
Bro.